Präsidentin hier die aktuelle Stunde auf
die von der Union beantragt wurde
ursprüngliche Titel war Leopard Blockade
der Bundesregierung beenden kein
vertrauensfall bei Verbündeten
verspielen jetzt hat es auch noch eine
Wortmeldung gegeben zum Geschäftsordnung
und die CDU hat ja auch prominente
Redner aufgefahren also möglicherweise
spricht als erster Redner der Nachfolger
des jetzigen Bundeskanzlers deshalb
beantrage ich für die afd-fraktion die
Herbeirufung des Bundeskanzlers nach
Paragraph 42 GEO und Artikel 43 des
Grundgesetzes zu dieser wichtigen
Debatte die sich jetzt hier im Rahmen
der aktuellen Stunde anband
Herr Brantner also zitiert für die AFD
den Bundeskanzler herbei der nicht auf
der Regierungsbank sitzt
von den anderen Fraktionen das ist nicht
der Fall dann lasse ich über diesen
Antrag abstimmen wer für den Antrag der
herbeizitierung ist den und die bitte
ich jetzt um ihr Handzeichen
die afd-fraktion wer ist dagegen
sind die koalitionsfraktion und die
Linke wer enthält sich das ist die
Fraktion der
cdu/csu damit ist der Antrag abgelehnt
und ich komme jetzt zur aktuellen Stunde
die von der cdu/csu-fraktion verlangt
worden ist zum Thema leopardblockade der
Bundesregierung beenden kein Vertrauen
bei Verbündeten verspielen als erstes
hat das Wort der Kollege Friedrich Merz
für die CDU CSU ja und die CDU geht
gleich mit ihrem ran und er wird
sicherlich bemängeln dass der
Verteidigungsminister nicht da ist liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir hätten
selbstverständlich den Antrag auf diese
aktuelle Stunde zurückgezogen wenn der
Bundeskanzler heute morgen über die
Entscheidung des Bundeskabinetts nun
doch Leopard 2 Panzer an die Ukraine zu
liefern im Wege eine Regierungserklärung
nicht nur dieses Parlament sondern auch
die deutsche Öffentlichkeit informiert
hätte statt gestern Abend über die
Bild-Zeitung
ich will hier für die cdu/csu-fraktion
feststellen diese Entscheidung ist
richtig wir halten sie für angemessen
und ich will hinzufügen niemand in
diesem Haus tut sich mit einer solchen
Entscheidung leicht wir haben am 27
April 1922 hier im Deutschen Bundestag
gemeinsam beschlossen die auch keine
auch mit militärischer Ausrüstung zu
helfen wir haben beschlossen auch
schwere Waffen zu liefern im Laufe des
Jahres 2022 hat sich die Notwendigkeit
panzerwaffen zu liefern auch
panzerwaffen westlicher Bauart als immer
dringlicher erwiesen dies ist die
Meinung nicht nur der Ukraine gewesen
sondern dies ist auch die Auffassung
einer ganzen Reihe von alliierten und
Verbündeten in der Europäischen Union
und in der NATO gewesen allein die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und die
Bundesregierung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland haben eine frühere
Entscheidung darüber verhindert und
verzögert und ich will ausdrücklich dem
Eindruck widersprechen der heute morgen
in der Befragung des Bundeskanzlers
entstanden ist als ob dies alles
sozusagen im Konsens mit allen Partnern
in der Europäischen Union entschieden
worden sei das Gegenteil ist richtig
meine Damen und
ich will es noch einmal unterstreichen
niemand von uns tut sich leicht mit
einer solchen schwerwiegenden
Entscheidung niemand aber wir hätten
schon erwartet dass es darüber hier im
Deutschen Bundestag eine intensivere
Diskussion über die Begründung der
Haltung der Bundesregierung in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten gegeben hätte
der Bundeskanzler der Bundeskanzler hat
die Öffentlichkeit und die Partner über
Wochen und Monate im Unklaren darüber
gelassen warum er denn eine solche
Entscheidung in diesem Umfang verzögert
warum hat er diese Entscheidung erst so
spät getroffen und meine Damen und
Herren ich füge eine zweite Beobachtung
oder eine zweite Feststellung hinzu die
schrillen Töne über die Waffenlieferung
sind nicht aus der
Oppositionsfraktion gekommen die
schrillen Töne sind aus ihren Reihen
gekommen meine Damen und Herren aus FDP
und grüner Fraktion insbesondere
wir sind hier immer zu einer sehr
abgewogenen Beurteilung der Lage
gekommen trotz ihrer Zwischenrufe meine
Damen und Herren wir haben allerdings
eines von ihnen erwartet und diese
Erwartung setzt sich fort Abstimmung in
solchen Fragen mit unseren Partnern in
der NATO und in der Europäischen Union
nicht eine Bundesregierung die getrieben
werden muss und dass sie getrieben
worden ist haben doch die Ereignisse
über den Jahreswechsel in aller
Deutlichkeit gezeigt bis hin zu der
ramsteinkonferenz in der letzten Woche
in der es offensichtlich ein schweres
Zerwürfnis zwischen dem amerikanischen
Verteidigungsminister und einigen
Vertretern der Bundesregierung auf
dieser Konferenz gegeben hat sie haben
eine meine entfernt die Bundesregierung
die Bundesregierung hat eine Chance
vertan und bei dieser Gelegenheit waren
wir nun in großer Zahl dabei es waren
auch Kolleginnen und Kollegen der SPD
der Grünen und der FDP-Fraktion am
letzten Sonntag in Paris warum hat der
Bundeskanzler diese Gelegenheit nicht
genutzt mit dem französischen
Staatspräsidenten zusammen zu sagen dass
es in dieser Woche in dieser Frage eine
gemeinsame Entscheidung der Nato-Partner
der Partner in der Europäischen Union
und vor allem der französischen und der
deutschen Regierung gibt warum hat der
Bundeskanzler diese Chance nicht genutzt
bei ihnen in den Koalitionsfraktionen
werden aus diesen Auseinandersetzungen
der letzten Tage und Wochen einige
Verletzungen zurückbleiben daran werden
Sie sich gegenseitig regelmäßig erinnern
das aber ist ihre Sache bedauerlich aber
ihre Sache der Schaden der entstanden
ist meine Damen und Herren in der NATO
und in der Europäischen Union dass man
dieser Bundesregierung nicht trauen kann
dass man sie treiben muss dass sie zu
Entscheidungen gedrängt werden muss dass
sie zögert und zaudert und dass sie eben
nicht das tut was der Bundeskanzler
mehrfach hier in seinen Reden und heute
Mittag auch in seiner Befragung zum
Ausdruck gebracht hat nämlich mit den
Partnern zusammen zu entscheiden dieser
Schaden der bleibt auch über den Tag des
heutigen der heutigen Entscheidung
hinaus ich will es noch einmal
ausdrücklich unterstreichen die wir für
richtig halten wie früher hätte
getroffen werden müssen und die vor
allem hätte getroffen werden müssen ohne
diesen Schaden bei unseren Partnern in
der Europäischen Union und in der NATO
herzlichen Dank
Friedrich Merz der Fraktionschef der
cdu/csu und Parteivorsitzender der CDU
hier hat noch mal begründet warum die
Aktuelle Stunde trotzdem stattfinden der
Bundeskanzler habe hier seine Schritten
nicht begründet vor dem parlamentaren
übrigens der Bundesverteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius sitzt auf der
Regierungsbank und so ist es ja
eigentlich auch richtig Rolf Mütze nicht
jetzt bei dieser Debatte SPD
wegen Kolleginnen und Kollegen zwei
Dinge lassen sich heute festhalten es
war ein
anstrengender aber notwendiger
Abstimmungsprozess der heute
seinen tragbaren Ergebnis gekommen ist
und auf der anderen Seite
zeigt sich heute wie wenig hilfreich ja
verantwortungslos meine Damen und Herren
Kommentare in den letzten Wochen waren
sie haben nicht geholfen sondern sie
haben insbesondere dem
Abstimmungsprozess den der Bundeskanzler
die die Bundesregierung von Anfang an
gewollt hat erschwert und ich bin mir
sicher nachträglich werden wir das noch
feststellen müssen und möglicherweise
auch bereuen hoffentlich von dem einen
oder anderen Dauerredner meine Damen und
Herren deswegen sage ich
gemeinsames Handeln ist
verantwortungsvoll und
voraussetzungsvoll weil es nämlich zwei
Dinge
erreicht in einem Jahr eines Krieges in
der Ukraine nämlich das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht was die Ukraine
aus der Kater der Vereinten Nationen
herleitet allen von denen die
internationales Recht achten und Herr
Kollege Merz auf der anderen Seite die
Sicherheit Deutschlands fest zu machen
auch das ist der notwendige
Abstimmungsprozess mit den Partnern
voraussetzungsvoll sind diese beiden
Dinge eben nicht in Talkshows zu
erreichen sondern nur in harte Arbeit in
harter
Diplomatie und ich sage allen den
die immer wieder so laut rufen sie
verfügen nicht über das notwendige
Hintergrundwissen was erforderlich ist
und zum zweiten sie sind nicht in der
Lage und sie tragen auch Gott sei Dank
keine Verantwortung meine Damen und
Herren
und ja der Kollege merkt natürlich gab
es
Zwischenrufe die auch zwischen den
Koalitionspartnern gewesen war aber sie
sagen sie hätten sich an dieser Debatte
nicht beteiligt entschuldigung ich sage
entschuldigung aber ich muss Ihnen zwei
Sätze vor sie ich meine nicht Sie
persönlich sondern ihre Fraktion ihr
Kollege Michael Brand schreibt heute
morgen in der Fuldaer Zeitung
Zitat die Feigheit von Scholz vor
Ideologen und Zynikern die Mütze nicht
in der SPD hat bereits viele tausende
Menschen das Leben gekostet und droht
den Krieg nach Deutschland zu bringen
wie widerlich meine Damen und Herren
sind diese Sätze von einer angeblich
verantwortungsvollen
Opposition
Herr Kollege Merzig kann ihn nur raten
wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie überhaupt Rat
Wünschen
orientieren sie sich an dem was wir
unser Land auch wichtig gewesen ist
nämlich die deutsche Einheit wieder
herzustellen
nach schwierigen wegen aber auch nach
Einladung von Helmut Kohl ist Willy
Brandt mit ihm zusammen nach Berlin
gekommen als die Mauer fiel und das
finde ich zeigt konstruktive
Oppositionen und Offenheit zwischen
demokratischen Parteien so wünschen Sie
es mir in der Zukunft und deswegen sage
ich Ihnen auch sie werden auch kein Teil
zwischen die
Sozialdemokratien und Sozialdemokraten
bringen Lars Klingbeil wird gleich das
Wort ergreifen wir haben gestern ein
wichtiges Papier zur Diskussion über die
Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik nach dem
Angriffskrieg Putins vorgelegt und ich
sage Ihnen das sind wichtige Bausteine
für eine zukünftige Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik die Sozialdemokraten
und Sozialdemokraten in diesem Jahrzehnt
weiter prägen wollen und meine Damen und
Herren zum Schluss
die Welt ist komplizierter als uns
manche vormachen wollen in
Twitter-Meldungen oder in kurzen
Kommentaren ich hatte Gelegenheit in der
Antwort auf den Bundeskanzler eine Karte
damals hier dem Deutschen Bundestag zu
zeigen welche Länder und wie groß diese
Länder sind die sich unserer
Schlussfolgerung aus dem Angriffskrieg
nicht anschließen und die wird man nicht
zur Seite schieben können sondern mit
denen muss man offen in einem
diplomatischen versuchen Konsens zu
treten und genau das hat der
Bundeskanzler getan und das hat uns die
Chance eröffnet meine Damen und Herren
nachdem China das nukleare Tabu
bekräftigt hat nachdem auf dem G20
Gipfel das nukleare Tabu bekräftigt
worden ist dass wir diese
Handlungsfreiheit haben die wir heute
gehabt haben nachdem der Bundeskanzler
seiner Entscheidung deine Entscheidung
glaube ich auch der USA und Frankreich
in den nächsten Stunden folgen wird zu
machen und deswegen sage ich kluge
Außenpolitik ist mehr als die Lieferung
von Waffen und das ist auch das
Versprechen der sozialdemokratischen
Fraktionen und Parteien vielen Dank
Rolf Mützenich hat hier Friedrich Merz
noch einmal vorgeführt dass durchaus
auch unangemessene Zwischenrufe aus der
Oppositionsfraktion CDU und CDU gekommen
sind nach dem März ja gesagt hat in die
Zwischenrufe sein alle aus der Ampel
gewesen Dino jetzt fraktionsschrift der
AFD
frau Präsidentin ich hätte mir natürlich
schon mal sehr gewünscht wenn der Titel
dieser aktuellen Stunde leopardblockade
immer noch Bestand hätte das hätte auch
die afd-fraktion absolut begrüßt das
muss ich als allererstes sagen und wenn
ich aktuell auch diese Debatte jetzt
hier verfolgt habe Herr Merz sie hatten
ja einiges hier schon gesprochen mit
Ihnen als Bundeskanzler hätten wir
bereits Kampfflugzeuge geliefert also
von daher ihre Heuchelei hier an dieser
Stelle das hat eigentlich gezeigt sieht
gehen genauso in diese Kriegstreiber
rein wie FDP und Grüne das ist
mittlerweile die Aufgabe der größten
Opposition in diesem Land
ich muss Ihnen sagen ich und wir fühlen
mit der ukrainischen Bevölkerung auch
vor Ort denn Kriegsangst und das ist das
Thema Kriegsangst verspüren mittlerweile
die Deutschen auch hier in unserem Land
aber werden die maßlosen und vor allen
Dingen die egozentrischen Forderungen
einiger ukrainischen Politiker die sich
ja jetzt schon wieder per Twitter
absondern noch immer mehr Waffen und
schneller zu liefern oder bewirken sie
im Prinzip eigentlich auch mehr als nur
diesen Brandbeschleuniger kann die
eu-kraine überhaupt gewinnen stehen hier
die Einsatz und der Einsatz der Mittel
im Verhältnis zum Ergebnis welche
Strategie verfolgt eigentlich die
Bundesregierung das ist auch Scholz
heute offen geblieben in der Frage Runde
wie gestellt wurde wollen sie eigentlich
den Bündnisfall provozieren so erscheint
es mittlerweile vielen in der deutschen
Bevölkerung die immer mehr Angst haben
dazu alle haben sie auch die Frage wo
sind eigentlich die Waffen geblieben die
wir und andere Länder schon geliefert
haben sind diese von der Ukraine oder
noch im Einsatz oder hat der Russe diese
längst zerstört auch das nicht
beantwortet sie suggerieren hier den
Bürgern das mit der Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern Leopard Russland besiegt
werden kann
wie viele Panzer möchten Sie denn
weltweit zusammensuchen um die
ausstattungstärke der russischen Armee
zu erreichen bzw auch zu übertreffen
laut Statista verfügt Russland 2022 über
ca 12.500 Kampfpanzer die Ukraine im
übrigen über ca 2600 damit stehen der
ukrainischen Armee fast 9 mal so viel
Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung wie aktuell
der Bundeswehr
Bundesverteidigungsministerium hat ja
dazu Auskunft gegeben mit ungefähr 20089
Leopard 2 Panzern das sind die Fakten
nun meldet sich natürlich die
Rüstungsindustrie blackrockner März
reibt sich schon die Hände rein Metall
hat wohl 239 Panzer die innerhalb von
zwei Jahren bereits stünden und ich
frage sie warum wurden diese nicht
längst für die Bundeswehr im übrigen
atüchtigt diese Panzer Werte Kollegen
schauen Sie sich die Lieferung aus der
Bundeswehr Beständen beziehungsweise die
zusätzlichen Beschaffung an die wir
bereits für diesen Krieg getätigt haben
wie lange braucht es wohl um unsere
Bestände der Bundeswehr wieder
aufzubauen sie und zuvor die CDU
plündern unsere Bundeswehr aus wie sieht
es wenn aktuell mit der
Verteidigungsbereitschaft der Bundeswehr
aus oder sind wir nun vollends von
Allianzen und Bündnissen abhängig meine
Damen und Herren mit ihren
Entscheidungen verlängern Sie aktiv
einen Konflikt und versperren sich
Friedensverhandlungen sie laufen Sehnen
Auges direkt ins offene Feuer ich muss
es so offen sagen direkt in den Dritten
Weltkrieg was ist also das Ziel der
Bundesregierung und auch der größten
Opposition CDU wollen Sie diesen Krieg
zu dem unseren machen und Deutschland
wieder in die Dunkelheit stürzen erst
liefern wir Ausrüstung dann leichte
Waffen dann schwere Waffen was ist das
nächste sind es dann deutsche Soldaten
die wir liefern und die einsatzbereit
sein sollen
am 2 februar am 2 Februar gedenken wir
dem 80 jahrestag der Schlacht um
Stalingrad mit all seinen Kriegstoten
ich empfehle Ihnen gerade von der FDP
allen den Besuch einer
Kriegsgräberstätte wo auch ich während
meiner Auslandsreisen regelmäßig einen
Kranz niederlege oder hier direkt vor
den Toren Berlins an den Seelower Höhen
fast jeder in diesem Hohen Haus kann
dort Familienmitglieder wiederfinden die
im Krieg zu Tode kam
die Lieferung von Waffen wird das Leid
vergrößern und viel schlimmer es werden
zahllose Tote zu beklagen sein dieser
Krieg hilft niemand auf dem europäischen
und asiatischen Kontinent und der glaubt
mit Waffenlieferung Frieden zu schaffen
ist wirklich mehr als naiv Druck erzeugt
Gegendruck
Allianzen und Freundschaften sind
aufrichtig und wahr wenn alle Seiten
alle Seiten die Last gemeinsam tragen in
diesem Fall werden wir als Deutsche und
wird Europa wieder mal einseitig
belastet der Krieg findet wieder vor
unserer Haustür statt unsere sogenannten
Freunde aus den Vereinigten Staaten
heizen die Situation immer weiter an
deren Rüstungsindustrie macht wieder
gute Geschäfte und kann die maroden
Staatsfinanzen sanieren schließlich
müssen sie sich die USA nicht um die
Sicherheit ihres Kontinents sorgen und
diese Sicherheit ist auf dem Kontinent
Europa in Gefahr und genau damit muss
Schluss sein Bündnisse ja Allianzen ja
aber doch nicht um den Preis der
Selbstaufgabe europa braucht Frieden und
muss eine souveräne Stellung in der Welt
erlangen und wir müssen zuerst den
Interessen unseres Landes und unserer
Bürger dienen sie haben als
Bundesregierung die Aufgabe Schaden von
Land und Leuten abzuwenden werden sie
endlich dieser Aufgabe gerecht vielen
der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
afd-fraktion hier in dieser aktuellen
Stunde die er noch mal aktueller
geworden ist durch die Entscheidungen zu
Leopard 2 Panzern nächster Redner ist
Jürgen Trittin der außer politische
Sprecher der Grünen Fraktion
das ist das Elend der Opposition da
schicken sie an märz und Herr Dobrind in
die Bütt und dann hat sich das Thema
erledigt und zur Strafe müssen Sie dann
die Reden von Herrn krupala anhören die
Reden eines Mitglieds einer Partei von
dem ein Abgeordneter Jahre lang ein Büro
in Moskau betrieben hat so viel zu
Ernsthaftigkeit ihre Argumentation an
dieser Stelle
es ist gut dass der Bundeskanzler heute
für Klarheit gesorgt hat Deutschland ist
nicht nur der zweitgrößte zivile
Unterstützer der Ukraine wir stellen
Zehntausende von Generatoren um den
Menschen die Last der Kälte durch den
russischen Bomben Terror zu nehmen vor
allem aber deutschland ist mit den USA
und mit Großbritannien einer der drei
großen militärischen Unterstützer der
Ukraine in ihrem Kampf gegen die
russische Aggression sind deutsche
gebhardpanzer die iranische Drohnen
abschießen es waren deutsche
Raketenwerfer und die Panzerhaubitze
2000 die die Ukraine die Befreiung
besetzter Gebiete ermöglicht haben und
damit hört es nicht auf am Freitag
wurden in Ramstein neue Zusagen gemacht
das vielleicht größte militärische
Unterstützungspaket am Montag ist im Rat
für auswerte Beziehung
noch einmal 500 Millionen in die
europäische peacefacellity zur
Beschaffung von Rüstungsgütern gegangen
das heißt 125 davon kommen aus
Deutschland das alles verschweigen Sie
Herr Merz das alles verschweigen sie
weil es ihnen unangenehm ist aber für
die Ukraine ist diese Hilfe
auch sie ist existenziell aber sie
reicht nicht wir müssen mehr machen
nehmen wir ernst was wir täglich
erfahren was unsere Dienste sagen
dann steht die Ukraine vor einer großen
Frühjahrsoffensive Russlands
der geplante aufwuchs der russischen
Armee auf 1,5 Millionen möglicherweise
zwei Millionen Soldaten und Söldner das
Leeren aller Depots zeigt worauf Putin
setzt er will mit einer Materialschlacht
die Ukraine überrennen und diese
zynische Politik kalkuliert den Tod von
tausenden Russen ein vor Sonne da vor
bachmund fällt heizt er jeden Tag 300
Menschenleben alle Zeichen stehen auf
eine russische Großoffensive und es ist
zynische Menschenverachtung dieser
Angriffskrieg diese Kriegsführung ist
verbrecherisch und das ist der
Hintergrund für diese Debatte
und ich würde mir wünschen
liebe Frau Wagenknecht Liebe seven
dadelem wenn Sie Ihren
antimiliteristischen Furor einmal nur
einmal gegen diese Politik von Putin
verwenden würden so aber sind ihre
Einlassungen im Ernst der Lage nicht
angemessen und ich will das mit aller
diplomatischen Zurückhaltung sagen dem
Ernst der Lage war auch nicht das
angemessen was die polnische Regierung
an dieser Frage veranstaltet hat ich bin
froh dass Annalena baerbock dies auf den
Boden der Tatsachen zurückgeholt hat man
kann schlecht darüber reden über einen
angeblich abgelehnten Antrag den man
noch nicht einmal gestellt hat
wir wollen
wir wollen ernsthaft verhindern dass
Russland die Ukraine überrennt
das ist in unserem ureigenen Interesse
wer es belohnt das mit gewaltgrenzen in
Europa verändert werden der gefährdet
die Sicherheit und den Frieden auch in
Deutschland
und ich weiß die Menschen hier im Lande
sind gespalten auch über die Lieferung
der Panzer
ich selber bin überzeugt davon ohne sie
wird die Ukraine Putin nicht stoppen
können aber die Menschen die das
Ablehnen sie haben Gründe dafür
ein Grund ist die Furcht vor einer
Eskalation vor einer Rutschbahn an deren
Ende ein Krieg der NATO mit Russland
stehen könnte
ja wir wollen die Ukraine unterstützen
aber wir wollen keine militärische
Auseinandersetzung zwischen der Nato und
Russland und es gibt die Gefahr der
Eskalation es gibt sie in jedem Krieg
der hat schon klausewitz darauf
hingewiesen
aber die Gefahr der Eskalation darf kein
Freibrief sein für Verbrecher die
glauben sie hätten die eskalationshoheit
die Antwort auf die Gefahr der
Eskalation muss sein wir müssen diese
Gefahr mindern und dabei die Ukraine
unterstützen das Rezept der Minderung
der Eskalation das liegt daran wir
müssen in der NATO Gemeinsamkeit
herstellen Gemeinsamkeit innerhalb der
NATO ist der beste Schutz gegen die
Eskalation und ich bin froh dass es den
Bundeskanzler
in freundlichen Gesprächen wie er das
genannt hat gelungen ist die USA zu
überzeugen sich an der Lieferung von
Panzern zu beteiligen Putins Rechnung
die NATO zu Spalten zwischen Europa und
den USA geht nicht auf so geht Führung
Führung geht nicht übrigens liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der cdu/csu
in Alleingänge Führung in der
multipolaren Welt geht nur in
Gemeinsamkeit vielen Dank
das Wort für die Fraktion DIE LINKE
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
vor 11 Monaten begann der Krieg Russland
gegen die Ukraine
280.000 tote Soldatinnen und Soldaten
noch beiden Seiten 10.000 zivile Opfer
und das klar zu sagen wir verurteilen
den Versuch Putins lieber Jürgen Trittin
Grenzen in Europa zu verschieben auf das
Schärfste da gibt es überhaupt kein
Zweifel in der Linken aber die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich hoffe dass
es in dem Hohen Haus auch ein Konsens
gibt dass dieser Krieg schnellstmöglich
enden soll es muss Schluss sein mit dem
Sterben mitten in Europa liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dafür
brauche ich die eskalo-lation und nicht
Eskalation der Bundeskanzler hat eben in
der regierungsbefragung gesagt wir
werden alles tun um eine Eskalation zu
verhindern was ist dann aber die
Realität wenn man sich die letzten 11
Monate anschaut es gab immer weiter eine
Eskalation das ist die Wahrheit ja ich
weiß in diesem Hohen Haus gibt es
offenbar eine Mehrheit dafür Leopard
weiter in den Krieg zu schicken die
cdu/csu-fraktion die Grünen mindestens
Teile der SPD und Teile der FDP sehen
Kampfpanzer als ein Beitrag zum Frieden
meine Fraktion ausdrücklich nicht meine
Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler hat
jetzt nachgegeben und ich sage deutlich
wir finden das falsch und wenn der neue
Verteidigungsminister sagt die ersten
Leopard Panzer werden in drei Monaten in
der Ukraine sein was für ein Verständnis
das Ziel muss sein dass es in drei
Monaten keinen Krieg mehr gibt in der
Ukraine meine Damen und Herren das muss
das Ziel sein angesichts der russischen
Ressourcen und der Bereitschaft der
russischen Führung Soldaten zu verheizen
wird dieser Krieg so weiter eskalieren
und es werden weitere hunderttausende
Menschen Leben geopfert werden wenn wir
nicht aus der Kriegslogik aussteigen
meine Damen und Herren ich empfehle
Ihnen dringend hören Sie nicht länger
auf ihr Bauchgefühlen es belügt sie
sondern sie sich nicht in den schlafz
des Boulevards der den Krieg anheizt
hören sie auf Experten ich will nur ein
zitieren der Rang höchste sie sollten
bisschen ruhiger und entspannter und
nachdenklicher sein bei den Grünen
erinnern Sie sich mal wo sie herkommen
der Rang höchste US-General Mike Melli
hat gesagt die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
ukrainischen militärischen Sieges
definiert als rausruf der Russen aus der
gesamten Ukraine einschließlich der von
ihnen beanspruchten Krim ist militärisch
gesehen nicht sehr hoch es gibt eine
selten Übereinstimmung des Generals mit
meiner Position und jetzt hören wir seit
Tagen von ihm wer nur nachdenklich ist
Kampfpanzer zu liefern ist ein Putin
Freund ehrlich gesagt sie beleidigen mit
solchen Dünnpfiff nicht nur ihren
eigenen Intellekt sondern auch die
Mehrheit der Staatengemeinschaft meine
Damen und Herren das ist die Wahrheit
die Lieferung von Kampfpanzern Markt im
Deutschen Bundestag eine Mehrheit haben
in der Bevölkerung ist das gegen Teil
der Fall in Ostdeutschland ist nicht mal
ein Drittel der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dafür ein Jahr zum Leopard beschädigt
dort ausdrücklich auch die Demokratie
meine Damen und Herren das ist die
Wahrheit mehr Nachdenklichkeit des
angesagt ich höre jetzt auch immer
wieder Deutschland wäre international
isoliert wenn das wenn wir keine
leopardliechner würden was für ein
Unsinn er wird sie mehr hat die Mehrzahl
der internationalen Staatengemeinschaft
hat nicht eine einzige Gewehrkugel
geliefert in diesen kriegswahnsinn die
Mehrheit der internationalen
Gemeinschaft weiß dass eine Atommacht
nicht militärisch zu besiegen ist die
weiß das Kampfpanzer kein Frieden
bringen meine Damen und Herren jede
Zurückhaltung jede Zurückhaltung
deutsche Kampfpanzer in eine Schlacht
mit russischen Truppen zu schicken ist
mehr als gerechtfertigt angesichts
unserer Geschichte 27 Millionen
sowjetbürgerinnen und so wird Bürger
diese historische Schuld werden auch
dazu dass man nachdenklich ist meine
Damen und Herren was die Wahrheit ist
was die Wahrheit ist der die gestrige
Meldung Aktienkurs von Rheinmetall auf
Rekordniveau ja die klatschen in die
Hände Rheinmetall kommt in die Dax das
ist ja ein wunderbares Ergebnis meine
Damen und Herren meine Damen und Herren
wer ohne strategisches Fundament immer
mehr und immer schwerere Waffen liefern
will der bleibt auch nicht bei
Kampfpanzer entstehen morgen
Kriegsschiffe mehr hat Jürgen tritt ihn
gerade gesagt mehr morgen Kriegsschiffe
übermorgen Kampfflugzeuge Tornados
Eurofighter flugverbotion dann hatte
Soldaten wo soll denn das Ändern Markus
Keim immerhin von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik der hat bei
Spiegel Online dazu folgendes
geschrieben mit einem derartigen
Freibrief ließ sich auch die Lieferung
taktischer Waffen an die ukrainische
Streitkräfte rechtfertigen ja selbst so
ein Unsinn wird gefordert ich kann die
Bundesregierung nur auffordern sagen sie
Nein zur weiteren Eskalation legen sie
endlich eine abgestimmte europäische
Friedens qualitative vor da sollten Sie
Ihre Anstrengung deutlich verstärken
meine Damen und Herren dankeschön
Dietmar Bartsch hat hier für die
Linksfraktion gesprochen und die
vorherigen Redner kritisiert und ich
schlechte ist der Obmann im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss für die FDP-Fraktion und der
nächste Rednern dieser aktuellen Stunde
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren also zu Beginn der
Faschismus hat uns mehrere Millionen
Tote in Europa gebracht und hat uns in
Krieg und Elend gestürzt
das hat der braune gemacht und ich
glaube die Partei die am nächsten kommt
es die von Herrn diesem Haus und der
Sozialismus hat Hunderte von Millionen
Menschen in Armut Hunger und in den Tod
geführt von den berühmten Führern die
offensichtlich alle bei ihnen noch in
den Büros hängen ich erinnere da an Maus
Stalin und diese alle hießen man sieht
was der Sozialismus gebracht hat die
sozialistischen Republiken im Nahen
Osten die sozialistischen Republiken in
Nord im Norden von Südamerika Venezuela
alles ganz großes Kino und dann hier
belehren an diesem historischen Tag wo
wir nach vielen vielen vielen Debatten
die es auch in unserer Koalition gibt
entsprechend zu
Überzeugung gelangt sind dass wir die
Panzer liefern und bei aller allerliebe
ja heute habe ich viel von Willy Brandt
gehört und auch von Helmut Schmidt ich
erinnere da auch anhand Dietrich Genter
weil Walter Scheel die alle zum Frieden
in Europa mit beigetragen haben
und auch diese würden heute hier stehen
und sagen wir können nicht anders als
unseren Frieden den wir in Europa mit
viel Mühe erarbeitet haben gemeinsam zu
verteidigen und die Verteidigung unseres
Friedens in Europa findet derzeit in der
Ukraine statt und das ist
nummerhistorischer Fakt und
dementsprechend ist es völlig richtig
dass diese von uns getragene
Bundesregierung zu dieser Entscheidung
gekommen ist und das steht für mich
völlig außer Frage die Ukraine hat uns
um diese Panzer gebeten sie brauchen sie
in ihrem Verteidigungskampf für Freiheit
und Demokratie gegen die Garantie Macht
die ihnen selber 1994 zugesagt hat dass
ihre nationale Integrität ihre
Bündnisfreiheit garantiert ist im
Budapester memorando 1997 schriftlich
noch mal bestätigt die Russische
Föderation ist der Aggressor und nicht
diese Bundesregierung oder wer auch
immer hier von Kriegstreiber reinspricht
und diese narrative die die ganze Zeit
aufgewiesen werden die wir hören müssen
jeden Tag über telegram und so weiter
verbreitet diesen ihre narrative die sie
versuchen dem deutschen Volk
einzutrichtern und diese narrative sind
schlicht und ergreifend falsch es ist
Putin der am 24.02 vergangenen Jahres
den Angriffsbefehl gegeben hat der dafür
gesorgt hat dass
150.000 Soldaten in ukrainisches
Territorium eingefallen sind der einen
vollen Angriff auf die Ukraine fährt und
es ist verdammt noch mal die Pflicht des
Westens wir sind nämlich auch
garantiemächte in Form der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika des United Kingdom
und Frankreichs und damals hat
Deutschland auch entsprechend an dem
Vertrag mitgearbeitet 94 beim Budapester
memorantum diesen Freunden in der
Ukraine zu helfen die ein demokratisch
gewählten legitimierten Präsidenten
haben und der vom ukrainischen Volk
dorthin gewählt worden ist wo er
hingewählt worden ist und was sie hier
versuchen darzustellen dass wir
Kriegstreiber werden ausgerechnet Rolf
Mütze nicht der immer noch im
Schützengraben vom Bonn liegt und ganz
genau weiß wofür er kämpft ja oder die
alte Dame SPD die jetzt ihre
außenpolitischen Grundlagen geändert hat
und wer klingt weil das gestern
vorgelegt hat auch bei uns in der Partei
die wir verwurzelt sind auch ebenfalls
im KFZ e-prozess OSZE und allem aber wir
haben feststellen müssen dass unsere
ganzen multilateralen
Komponenten nicht genügt haben und wer
war es denn der vor dem Krieg nach
Peking gereist ist es war Putin der vor
den Olympischen Spielen dort war und
seine Versicherungspolice gezogen hat
die Chinesen sehen momentan dass das
kein schlauer Akt war und versuchen sich
halbwegs wieder daraus zurückzuziehen
aber solange Putin diesen Krieg nicht
beenden möchte Friedensverhandlungen
ablehnt und
waffenstillstandsverhandlung was ich
heute morgen hier gehört habe die
Ukraine haben kurz vor Tores lustig vom
Boris Johnson davon abhalten lassen dass
es zufrieden kommt das ist hane Büchener
Unsinn ist Verschwörungstheorie und ist
diesem Hause hier in Wahrheit wirklich
nicht würdig ich bin dankbar Liebe SPD
das sämtliche Bremsen für den Kanzler
nun gelöst worden sind ich bin dankbar
der Grünen die kommen nämlich aus der
Friedensbewegung dass sie sofort erkannt
haben worum es geht bei diesem Krieg und
ich bin bei unserem Finanzminister das
wird die 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr zur Verfügung gestellt haben
und ich bin dankbar dass die größte
Oppositionspartei Gott sei Dank die
Union und nicht die anderen beiden die
hier noch sitzen müssen dass die im
Endeffekt unseren Kurs mittragen und
dass wir gemeinsam der Ukraine zur Seite
stehen darum geht es in diesem ganzen
Fall und diesen ganzen Krieg und
hoffentlich können wir den Frieden in
Europa so erhalten wie in unsere
Gründungsväter in dieser Republik
gemeinsam aufgebaut haben vielen Dank
Alexander Dobrindt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir kritisieren
nicht die Entscheidung dass die
Bundesregierung den Leopard 2 Panzer
liefern will wir unterstützen sogar
diese Entscheidung wir haben sie sogar
eingefordert aber wir kritisieren die
Art des Umgangs mit dieser Lieferung das
wie und wann und vor allem diesen
untauglichen Versuch das Zögern über
Wochen und Monate jetzt zur Strategie zu
erklären meine Damen und Herren
das Problem lieber Kollege Mütze nicht
das war doch nicht dass sie sich mit
allen Bündnispartnern abstimmen mussten
das Problem war doch dass unsere
Bündnispartner längst abgestimmt waren
aber die Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung gefehlt hat das ist die
Wahrheit an der Stelle
[Applaus]
da gibt es ja eine Reihe von
Wortmeldungen die das auch belegen weil
sie dazwischen scheint das würde nicht
stimmen die rammstein-konferenz die war
am Freitag am vergangenen die
Wortmeldungen der Nachricht kann Ihnen
die Vorlesen Frau stark Zimmermann hat
sich ja öffentlich gegenüber den Medien
geäußert und dann von gesprochen dass
Deutschland leider gerade versagt
verziert wörtlich davon gestochen die
Geschichte schaut auf uns und
Deutschland hat leider gerade versagt
man könnte das beliebig weiter aufzählen
an dieser Stelle und ich will auch Ihnen
sagen sehr geehrter Kollege Mütze nicht
ich verstehe natürlich die Empörung über
manche Twittermeldungen die es gibt vor
allem gegenüber ihrer Person aber dann
bitte aufregend über die Meldungen die
aus ihrer eigenen Koalition kommen Ihnen
bezüglich
der polnische Ministerpräsident hat der
Ampel noch vor zwei Tagen vorgeworfen
dass die Verzögerungstaktik inakzeptabel
sei er hat sogar den Verdacht geäußert
dass Deutschland die Leopard Allianz
sabotieren wollte der lettische
Außenminister hat noch mal deutlich
gesagt vor zwei Tagen es gäbe überhaupt
keine guten Argumente mehr warum man
Kampfpanzer dicht bereitstellen könnte
meine Damen und Herren anscheinend
wussten bis zum heutigen Tag unsere
europäischen Partner nicht dass sie
diese Entscheidung treffen wollen das
nennen sie abgestimmt von wegen meine
Damen und Herren
der Bundeskanzler hat hier
vorhin in der regierungsbefragung gesagt
er trifft keine Entscheidung die eine
Gefahr für die Sicherheit Deutschlands
ist unsere Partner empfinden ihr Zögern
als das größte Risiko für die Sicherheit
Deutschlands
der französische Präsident hat es ihnen
auch noch mal am Wochenende ins
Stammbuch geschrieben man wird nicht nur
an seinen Entscheidungen gemessen
sondern auch an den Entscheidungen die
man nicht trifft mehr muss man dazu
eigentlich nicht sagen bezüglich
abgestimmt und ich darf auch an der
Stelle sagen weil Lars kling weil sie
hier noch zu Wort kommen was den guten
Umgang mit unseren Partnern anbelangt
sie fordern ja ständig die Führungsrolle
Deutschlands in Europa ein was diese
Ampel aber einnimmt ist die
Außenseiterrolle in Europa so kann man
nicht zusammenarbeiten mit unseren
Partnern
wir haben am 28 April vergangenen Jahres
eine Entscheidung gemeinschaftlich hier
getroffen die schweren Waffen in die
Ukraine zu liefern jetzt neun Monate
neun Monate nach dieser Entscheidung
werden dann möglicherweise Leopard
Panzer geliefert das ist eine Latenzzeit
die ist diese Krisensituation
schlichtweg nicht angemessen mitten in
einem Krieg mitten in Europa und der
Bundeskanzler hat heute davon gesprochen
dass das die neue Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit sei neun Monate Zaudern
und zögern das ist die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit die unsere Partner von
ihnen wahrnehmen so schaut es aus
und ich bitte Sie dringend an dieser
Stelle eine neue
deutschland-geschwindigkeit an den Tag
zu legen wenn es darum geht die 100
Milliarden umzusetzen der Bundesminister
der Verteidigung ihre Vorgängerin hat
versprochen zehn Milliarden Euro an
munitionsbeschaffung im Jahr 2022
umzusetzen davon ist nichts aber auch
gar nichts geschehen die zwei Prozent
Ziel sie stehen nicht im Haushalt auch
für die nächsten Jahre nicht das ist
ihre Aufgabe das umzusetzen ich darf an
der Stelle der Bundesminister Pistorius
aber auch die Gelegenheit wahrnehmen
hier im Deutschen Bundestag ihnen für
ihr neues Amt viel Erfolg zu wünschen
aufrichtig viel Erfolg an dieser Stelle
darf Ihnen aber auch mitteilen sie haben
als Bundesminister auch das Recht in
einer aktuellen Stunde zu sprechen
Herr Kollege das waren die letzten Worte
ihrer aus
erwähnt hat wir wollen alle den Frieden
lieber Kollege Bartsch Frieden wird
nicht dadurch geschaffen dass man der UK
eine die Selbstverteidigung nicht
wahrnehmen lasst Frieden wird dadurch
geschaffen wenn die Ukraine sich selbst
verteidigen kann und diesen Status
stellen wir hier meine Damen und Herren
Alexander Dobrindt war das für die
Unionsfraktion die SPD will sich neu
sortieren in ihrer Position zur Außen-
und Sicherheitspolitik und
SPD-Mann hat gerade am Montag einen
Entwurf für ein Positionspapier den
Partei Präsidium vorgelegt jetzt spricht
er hier im Deutschen Bundestag frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege Dobrindt
vielleicht noch mal im Büro bescheid
sagen ich glaube das war die Rede die
gestern geschrieben wurde und da wurden
die neuen Realitäten durch Entscheidung
der Bundesregierung nicht eingearbeitet
aber lassen Sie mich doch mal darüber
reden worum es hier eigentlich geht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
erleben seit dem 24 Februar ein brutalen
ein völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
durch Russland gegen die Ukraine wir
haben hier im Parlament viele
weitreichende Entscheidungen getroffen
wir haben tiefgehende ernste Diskussion
geführt über eine Situation von der wir
alle gehofft hatten dass wir sie nie
wieder erleben müssen das mitten in
Europa mit militärischer Gewalt Grenzen
verschoben werden dass ein souveräner
Staat in seiner Integrität angebrochen
wird angegriffen wird und dass wir jeden
Tag erleben müssen dass Menschen durch
Putins Armee sterben
und wissen Sie ich habe in den letzten
Tagen mich manches Mal gefragt ob eine
Diskussion wie wir sie geführt haben
ob sie angemessen ist dieser Situation
diesem Leid dem die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer ausgesetzt sind und ich will
deswegen hier ganz zu Beginn sagen weil
es nie außer Acht geraten darf putin ist
der Kriegsverbrecher wir senden hier aus
Deutschland seit dem 24 Februar ein
Signal wo ich auch stolz darauf bin dass
wir das häufig und oftmals in großer
Einigkeit tun wir stehen als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland als Regierung
als Parlament doch in der großen Zahl
solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und darum muss es doch auch in einer
aktuellen Stunde wie heute gehen
und
ich finde auch dass wir
immer wieder betonen müssen welche
Schritte wir gegangen sind seit dem 24
Februar wir haben mit einem Grundsatz
der deutschen außensicherheitspolitik
gebrochen
und wir liefern Waffen in ein
Kriegsgebiet damit die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine die mutig kämpfen und wir alle
bewundern diesen Mut damit Sie sich
selbst verteidigen können und wir sehen
doch auch dass es unsere Waffen unsere
Unterstützung sind die helfen das
Geländegewinne da sind das Städte
zurückerobert werden dass die russische
Aggression zurückgedrängt wird
und ich bin dem neuen
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
dankbar für die Signale die an den
ersten sechs Tagen seiner amtszeitgesetz
hat und ich will das hier mal sagen weil
das in den Hintergrund geraten ist eine
Konferenz in Ramstein bei der die
Bundesregierung ein Paket mit 1,1
Milliarden auf den Weg gebracht hat 1,1
Milliarden an militärischer
Unterstützung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist gut dass die
Bundesregierung das getan hat und ich
bin dem Minister ich bin dem
Bundeskanzler und allen anderen die
daran beteiligt waren dankbar für das
klare Signal das von Rammstein
ausgegangen ist
und wenn der Kollege Dobrindt hier sagt
man unterstützt die Entscheidung des
Bundeskanzlers aber es sei die Art und
Weise wieder mit umgegangen wurde dann
will ich das jetzt schon gerne mal
konkret wissen der Bundeskanzler hat
immer klar gesagt es gibt drei
Prinzipien wir stimmen uns sehr ab und
Bündnis wir werden selbst nicht
Kriegspartei und es gibt keine
Alleingänge lieber Kollege Dobrindt
welcher dieser drei Grundsätze stößt
denn bei der Union auf Widerspruch das
finde ich schon spannend dass mal zu
hören aber da hat er sich nicht zu
geäußert übrigens auch die klare Aussage
von Tag eins wir bewegen uns im Bündnis
und es gibt für uns keine rote Linien
wenn es darum geht
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine zu
unterstützen
aber ich sag hier auch das sind Zeiten
von großer Tragweite von Krieg und
Frieden wo wir doch alle auch in den
Wahlkreisen sorgen und Unsicherheiten
erleben wo doch Nachdenklichkeit und
auch abwägen mal erlaubt sein muss
wusste auch darum geht dass man nicht
dann Dinge verkündet wenn irgendwer das
gerade auf Twitter oder in den großen
fordert sondern dann wenn Dinge auch im
Bündnis geklärt sind und ich will das
hier klar sagen das ist ein großer
diplomatischer Erfolg von Olaf Scholz
und von dieser Bundesregierung dass man
jetzt im Bündnis abgestimmt mit
europäischen mit den transatlantischen
Partnern dass man dort einen Schritt
weitergeht und dass wir jetzt die
Ukraine stärken dadurch dass wir
Kampfpanzer liefern das ist ein großer
Erfolg und ich ertrage nicht wie das
rein geredet wird von der Opposition
Friedrich Merz
ich will das hier schon sagen das genüle
aus der Union in den letzten Tagen
Alexander Dobrindt hätte es jetzt machen
können dass man sich für Michael Brandt
und seine unhaltbaren Worte hier
entschuldigt auch das hat er nicht getan
aber die CDU
Herr Merz die CDU ist doch die Partei
von Konrad Adenauer der für die
Westintegration steht die Partei von
Helmut Kohl die für die europäische
Integration steht von Angela Merkel die
dafür gesorgt hat dass Deutschland einen
guten internationalen Hof hat und dieses
gnöle sie treten den Rasen kaputt als
Union auch sie fallen der
Bundesregierung in den Rücken das ist
doch unwürdig was sie machen Herr märz
und ich sage Ihnen sie können das besser
bitte kommen Sie zum Schluss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche mir
dass wir eine Diskussion in der
Tragweite von Krieg und Frieden dass wir
sie angemessener führen als sich das in
den letzten Tagen erlebt habe ich bin
der Bundesregierung dankbar dafür dass
wir die Ukraine stärken und ich wünsche
mir dass wir das geschlossen als
DemokratInnen und Demokraten weiter tun
vielen Dank
ich möchte nur am Rande darauf hinweisen
dass die Geschäftsführung für jede Frau
die der Mann in diesem Plenarsaal gilt
ein aktuelle Stunde besteht aber in fünf
Minuten Beitrag und sein fünf Minuten 45
Sekunden ist ja schon ein bisschen viel
weil alle anderen auch die Anspruch
hätten dann entsprechend berücksichtigen
zu werden über die Kollegen als nächste
das Wort die Kollegen die Burger
Thüringen Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen zu Recht diskutieren wir
seit Monaten über Waffenlieferungen in
die Ukraine es ist wichtig dass wir auch
in dieser Frage solidarisch an der Seite
der Ukraine stehen die Ukraine muss in
der Lage sein sich selbst verteidigen zu
können aber
Solidarität mit der Ukraine hat viele
Facetten sie hat zum Beispiel eine
innenpolitische Facette Solidarität
zeigt sich auch darin wie wir mit
ukrainischen geflüchteten hier vor Ort
umgehen
und auch wenn die Hilfsbereitschaft in
der Bevölkerung ungebrochen ist so frage
ich mich ehrlich gesagt bei den
Äußerungen ihres Parteivorsitzenden
lieben Union wie es wirklich um die
Solidarität steht christlich
demokratische Werte sind meiner Meinung
nach auf jeden Fall anders aus
[Applaus]
wir alle hier wissen wie schlecht die
humanitäre Lage in der Ukraine ist
Russland setzt gezielt explosionswaffen
in Wohngebieten ein sie attackiert die
Strom Wasser und Energieversorgung und
sie bombardieren Krankenhäuser
tausende Schulen im ganzen Land wurden
bereits beschädigt oder komplett
zerstört
Menschen verlieren jeden Tag ihr Zuhause
Kinder verlieren jeden Tag ihre Kindheit
die Gesundheitsversorgung vor Ort ist
katastrophal es ist dunkel und kalt in
vielen Teilen des Landes
mit der Unterstützung und Höhe von mehr
als einer Milliarde Euro hat die
Bundesregierung im letzten Jahr gezeigt
dass wir unser Verantwortung bewusst
sind diese humanitäre Katastrophe
abzumildern wir schaffen dabei gemeinsam
mit nicht Regierungsorganisationen
Wohnraum für Menschen auf der Flucht wir
unterstützen die Instandsetzung von
Stromnetzen und Wasserinfrastruktur wir
helfen die Gesundheitsversorgung zu
sichern und wir unterstützen darüber
hinaus auch die Nachbarländer molder und
die Ukraine und auch die Länder im
globalen Süden dabei die Auswirkungen
des Krieges zu bewältigen
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich mich
ganz herzlich bei den vielen Kommunen in
Deutschland bedanken die ihre
Partnerkommunen in der Ukraine
unterstützen beispielsweise mit
medizinischen Produkten mit Verpflegung
und Kälteschutz Liebe Kommunen das ist
Solidarität vielen Dank dafür
und während in der letzten Woche und
auch hier im Plenum in der
Öffentlichkeit vor allen Dingen über
Waffen diskutiert wurde stellt das BMZ
und das Auswärtige Amt bereits gemeinsam
mit der Ukraine die Weichen für eine
partnerschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
für ein Wiederaufbau und die spannende
Frage dabei ist wie schaffen wir ein
Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine zu gestalten
denn nicht nur den Zugang zur eu-ebnet
sondern nachhaltig inklusiv und
feministisch ist
und ich glaube persönlich dass dabei
drei Aspekte von besonderer Bedeutung
sind
der erste Aspekt die gezielte Einbindung
der Kommunen und der Zivilgesellschaft
denn die Menschen vor Ort wissen am
besten was Sie brauchen
und die Mitbestimmung von Frauen von
jungen Menschen und marginalisierten
Gruppen ist dabei natürlich unabdingbar
der zweite Faktor der glaube ich wichtig
ist eine nachhaltige und 1,5 Grad
konformer wieder aufbauen und ich weiß
das klingt gerade irgendwie ein bisschen
grotesk wenn wir jetzt schon über
Wiederaufbau reden aber ja wenn wir über
humanitäre Hilfe reden und darüber wie
es den Menschen vor Ort geht dann müssen
wir auch darüber reden wie wir schaffen
zum Beispiel das Häuser wieder aufgebaut
werden aber mit nachhaltigen Materialien
wir müssen darüber reden wie wir die
Ukraine darüber bei unterstützen können
Energiesysteme aufzubauen die eben von
Wind Wasser und Sonne angetrieben worden
sind und ja wir müssen die Ukraine auch
darin unterstützen einen Umbau zu einer
nachhaltigen Wirtschaft zu haben die
eben auch vor Ort gerade jetzt auch
Arbeitsplätze schafft damit die Menschen
vor Ort ein Einkommen haben
und der letzte Punkt ist es braucht eine
resiliente und krisenfeste Finanzierung
statt Kredite zu vergeben die
voraussichtlich in den kommenden
Jahrzehnten nicht zurückgezahlt werden
können und die Ukraine und auch Moldau
und ein unglaublichen Druck bringen
appelliere ich an unsere Partnerinnen in
der innerhalb der EU mehr Zuschüsse
statt Kredite zu vergeben das ist eine
nachhaltige und vorausschauende
Finanzierung
mit diesen und noch mit vielen vielen
weiteren Punkten können wir gemeinsam an
der Zukunft der Ukraine arbeiten und als
verlässlicher und solidarischer Partner
in auftreten denn liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Solidarität ist viel mehr als die
Debatte über deutsche panzerlieferung
vielen dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
das nächste Redner das Wort der
Alexander Müller FDP-Fraktion und
Alexander Müller ist der
verteidigungspolitische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Ukraine verteidigt tapfer
ihr Land gegen einen brutalen Aggressor
der täglich brutale kriegsvergleichen
Kriegsverbrechen begeht Russland darf
diesen grausam und völkerrechtswidrigen
Krieg nicht gewinnen denn es wäre der
Sieg des Unrechts über das Recht das
wäre der Rückfall in eine Zeit des der
Anarchie ohne geltendes Völkerrecht es
wäre das Signal das Starten sich einfach
mit brutaler Gewalt nehmen können was
sie von anderen wollen wenn wir grenzen
wieder gewaltsam verschieben lassen dann
riskieren wir noch mehr Leid und krieg
die Ukraine kämpft für ihr eigenes
Überleben sie kämpft für ihre Freiheit
und für ihre Demokratie und damit für
unsere gemeinsamen Werte und deswegen
hat sie unsere volle Solidarität
verdient
es ist gut dass heute eine Entscheidung
verkündet wurde wir finden die richtig
und eine große Mehrheit in diesem
Parlament unterstützt diese Entscheidung
auch was in dieser Debatte ein bisschen
erschreckend fand ist die
Übereinstimmung der Rednerinnen und
Redner von der AFD und der Linken denn
es muss doch jedem bekannt sein
dass es das Demokrat das Diplomatie
nicht weiterhilft es gäbe ohne westliche
Waffenlieferungen gäbe ist die Ukraine
in der heutigen Form nicht mehr und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir die
Ukraine weiterhin unterstützen und ich
bin
vielen Dank war die den Weg für diese
Entscheidung geebnet haben das ist
natürlich meine eigene Fraktion das sind
aber auch Bündnis 90 die Grünen die sehr
früh den Weg dafür bereitet haben es ist
zugegebenermaßen auch die Unionsfraktion
die eine Rolle gespielt hat dabei aber
auch viele Sozialdemokratinnen und
Sozialdemokraten die in einer
schwierigen gewissensabwägung sich ganz
klar geäußert haben die Haltung gezeigt
haben insgesamt haben wir heute eine
gute Entscheidung erfahren und das ist
auch wichtig im abgestimmt mit unseren
mit unseren Partnern international dass
wir diese diese Lieferung machen und wir
brauchen uns auch nicht verstecken
international es ist tatsächlich so all
dieses Gerede dass Deutschland angeblich
zu lahm wäre und nichts machen würde wir
sind international vom Volumen von
militärischer Unterstützung auf Platz
drei und von der finanziellen
Unterstützung mit 28,3 Milliarden sind
wir sogar auf Platz 1 also Deutschland
tut wirklich viel und ich bin im
Minister Pistorius besonders dankbar
dass er am Freitag die Entscheidung
getroffen hat konsequent zu analysieren
was haben wir an Ressourcen was wir noch
zusammen
glauben können denn es ist es ist davon
auszugehen dass leider dieser Krieg
nicht im nächsten Monat vorbei ist der
Krieg kann noch lange dauern und wir
müssen einen Plan haben wie wir
konsequent weiter unterstützen können
und die Mittel die wir in der Bundeswehr
abgeben können sind begrenzt und
deswegen ist es richtig dass jetzt
geprüft wird was ist ein gebrauchter
Material da was kann wann repariert
werden und was kann wie abgegeben werden
Herr Minister das war eine sehr gute
Entscheidung für die sind wir Ihnen sehr
dankbar
und dann kommen wir
zum zu dieser aktuellen Stunde die uns
die unionsfraktionen heute beschert hat
mit dem Titel kein Vertrauen bei
Verbündeten verspielen man will damit so
den Eindruck vermitteln die
Bundesregierung würde Vertrauen bei
Verbündeten spielen und das trieft doch
vor Ironie erinnern wir uns doch mal wer
hat denn damals in Wales diesen 2%
Beschluss gemacht das war unter der
Regierung Angela Merkel dass die
Verträge dort die Abmachungen
geschlossen wurden und es ist über Jahre
über viele Jahre nie gelungen an dieses
2% Ziel heranzukommen das waren die
Verbündeten die uns dafür immer wieder
kritisieren haben wie Lahm Deutschland
ist dass Deutschland seine Verträge
nicht erfüllt da haben wir uns
international isoliert und ich brauche
die ganzen Beispiele doch gar nicht
nennen wir kennen die die Sachen wo die
Welt über uns gelacht hat ob das die
gospok war das war unter Ministerin von
der Leyen das war die 13-fachung des
reparaturbudgets hat viele Jahre
gedauert es war die ausschreiben das
wären transporthubschraubers wo man für
jede Schraube vorschreiben wollte
welches die deutsche Unternehmen die
einzubauen hat es war das Sturmgewehr
die Ausschreibung die aufgehoben wurde
es war die berateraffäre mit
Untersuchungsausschuss die die
Digitalisierung der Bundeswehr über
viele Jahre gelähmt hat es war die 700
Millionen Euro Drohne die nur für ein
Museum entwickelt wurde also wenn es
darum geht dass wir uns international
lächerlich gemacht haben dann waren das
Entscheidungen der der früheren
Regierung aber nicht der jetzigen
Regierung im Gegenteil diese Regierung
hat im ersten Jahr bereits mehr für die
Sicherheit unseres Landes getan als
viele Regierungen vorher wir haben mit
der 100 Milliarden Finanzierung schon
deutlich mehr getan um auf das zwei
Prozent Ziel hinzukommen wir haben mit
dem beschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
einen ersten wichtigen Schritt gemacht
die Beschaffung zu beschleunigen und da
werden weitere kommen wir haben andere
Entscheidungen getroffen wie die
Bewaffnung der Drohnen dass Sie unsere
Soldaten in Zukunft besser schützen
können wir haben die Bestellung des
Tornado Nachfolgers in die Wege gebracht
den schweren Transporthubschrauber das
Sturmgewehr all diese Bestellungen
bringen wir jetzt auf den Weg
haben den Knoten gelöst beim fk-system
und wir werden noch viele weitere
wichtige Entscheidungen nehmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ganz am Schluss
will ich noch einen Gruß versenden an
einen Staatspräsidenten in Europa der
sinnbildlich wie kein anderer dafür
steht dass es eine Nation eint im Kampf
für Freiheit und Demokratie herr
Präsident zielensky herzlichen
Glückwunsch zum 45 Geburtstag vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
Geburtstagsgrüße von Alexander Müller
aus der FDP Fraktion und Jürgen hart
spricht nun als nächstes er ist der
Sprecher für auswärtige Politik der
Unionsfraktion Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich möchte beginnen mit einigen Worten
an die Werten vorräder Lars Klingbeil
und Rolf Mütze nicht mit dem wir bei
viele Jahre ja auch konstruktive gute
Gespräche geführt haben
überlasse ich finde den Vorwurf des
gnöhles an uns unpassend
wir haben im April diesen Jahres gesagt
es muss Blick auf die Unterstützung der
Ukraine mehr geben als nur 5000 Helme
wir haben dann gemeinsam
einen Antrag Ende April ich glaube zwar
der 28 im Bundestag verabschiedet wo wir
das beschlossen haben wir haben dann im
Mai einen weiteren Antrag der cdu/csu
eingebracht hier im Bundestag den haben
sie abgelehnt wo wir gesagt haben wir
möchten das auch schwere Waffen an die
Ukraine geliefert werden wir haben im
September einen Antrag an den Deutschen
Bundestag gerichtet wo wir sagen
angesichts der schwierigen militärischen
Lage müssen wir auch Kampfpanzer zur
Verfügung stellen idealerweise im
Verbund mit anderen dieser Antrag liegt
zurzeit Wochen im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
und wird jedes Mal von der Mehrheit der
Koalition von der Tagesordnung abgesetzt
und wir haben letzte Woche Donnerstag
ein ähnlichen Antrag hier wiederum
eingebracht und jetzt macht die
Bundesregierung das was wir seit Mai
fordern
und Herr Mütze nicht beschimpft uns
statt sein Bundeskanzler zu beschimpfen
dass er jetzt das macht weil sie
Opposition will das finde ich also schon
etwas merkwürdig
wir haben uns im übrigen wir haben uns
im übrigen allen Debatten die wir hier
zu diesem Thema geführt haben mit
äußerster Sorgfalt und mit Sensibilität
diesem schwierigen Thema gewidmet sie
haben hier von diesem Punkt keinen CDU
csu-redner gehört in Debatten der hier
in irgendeiner Weise
übergriffige oder unverschämte Anmerkung
Richtung Regierung gemacht hat wir haben
es immer sehr ernst genommen dass es
eine schwierige Entscheidung ist und wir
haben gesagt wir müssen den Mut haben
die zu treffen und wir haben in den
letzten Wochen beobachtet das nicht etwa
der Bundeskanzler andere animiert und
ermutigt hat etwas zu tun sondern nur
Gegenteil andere immer lauter und immer
schonungsloser die Forderungen an die
Bundesregierung gerichtet haben nicht im
übrigen Mitglieder der
regierungskoalitionszimmer Mann wir
haben gerade in der letzten Woche noch
mal die Auseinandersetzung gehabt dass
das als ausländische Staatschefs und
Verteidigungsminister in Deutschland
angeklopft haben wir haben den Wunsch
abholen gehabt auf Genehmigung der
rüstungsexperte wir haben am weiter
Rammstein gehabt am Donnerstag in der
Debatte sagt Dietmar niethan von der SPD
zu mir ich wüsste ja auch dass am
Freitag beschlossen wird dass die Panzer
kommen ich wusste es nicht Klammer auf
er lag schief ich schlag nicht schief so
wir haben am Sonntag das erlebt dass der
Bundeskanzler neben dem französischen
Staatspräsidenten steht und der
französische Staatspräsident sagt wir
werden nicht nur an dem gemessen was wir
machen sondern auch an dem gemessen was
wir nicht machen das war doch ganz klar
eine Botschaft Frankreichs Deutschland
belebt bewege dich ich finde es gut dass
Deutschland sich jetzt bewegt aber den
Eindruck zu erwecken das Olaf Scholz an
der Spitze der Bewegung stand und nicht
wie es wirklich vereinbremse Häuschen
saß das ist ja nun wirklich eine
ziemlich steile Geschichte
möchte ganz kurz noch
zwei drei Aspekte ansprechen also dass
die das Bundeskabinett heute morgen
beschlossen hat die Panzer zu liefern wo
er Pistorius jetzt erstmal beschlossen
hat zu zählen wie viel überhaupt da sind
ist ja auch und wie eine falsche
Reihenfolge ja das war ja auch irgendwie
ein eine doch ziemliche Hilfsbrücke zu
sagen wir müssen erstmal gucken was wir
haben jetzt hat man entschieden das
finden wir richtig es darf aber
natürlich keine Lücke in der Bundeswehr
gerissen werden und deswegen wäre es gut
gewesen wenn die Bundesregierung
vielleicht auch auf der Basis einer
Position die nicht die ich nicht teil
aber die ich akzeptieren könnte dass sie
sagt okay wir wollen noch nicht
entscheiden Panzer zu liefern aber wir
wollen uns in die Lage versetzen ist
vielleicht tun zu können vielleicht auch
als Warnung an Moskau Moskau du hast es
in der Hand ob wir gezwungen uns
gezwungen sehen das zu tun oder nicht
dann hätten wir im Sommer die Panzer
modernisieren können also instand setzen
können Leo 1 Leo zwei die bei der
Rüstungsindustrie stehen wir hätten
vielleicht auch den ein oder anderen
ukrainischen Soldaten schon mal
ausbilden können wir hätten dafür sorgen
können dass Munition da ist und dann
wäre jetzt Entscheidungsfähigkeit
gegeben jetzt ist entschieden worden
jetzt dauert es Monate bis diese Panzer
zum Einsatz kommen und ich hoffe dass
sie nicht zu spät kommen denn der die
früher als Offensive der Ukraine der der
Russen gegen die Ukraine wird ja nicht
bis zum Sommer warten ich stelle ganz
konkret die Frage an die Bundesregierung
wie das jetzt weitergeht in der
konkreten Umsetzung heute morgen im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss und ich habe mir
sagen lassen von den Kollegen
verteilungsausschuss war es ähnlich
haben wir noch nichts gar nichts
konkretes dazu gehört da konnte man
nicht mal die Stückzahl bestätigen also
dass das irgendwie ein großer Plan war
der mit großer Generalität des
Bundeskanzlers vorgetragen wurde und
umgesetzt wurde das glaube ich nicht und
das glaubt auch niemand anders
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege hat Jürgen hart
verweist hier noch mal auf
Ungenauigkeiten ist seine Meinung nach
unter anderem eben wie viele Panzer
überhaupt in in der Bundeswehr gerade
zur Verfügung stehen Robert Vahle ist
fraktionslos unter dementsprechend zwei
Minuten in dieser aktuellen Stunde
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
erstens meiner Meinung nach ist diese
Entscheidung zur Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern an silensky eine falsche
Entscheidung denn sie dreht nur die
kriegsspirale eine Schraube weiter und
wieder werden deutsche Panzer gegen
Russland Rollen das haben dort viele
Menschen noch in ihrem Gedächtnis und
nicht in einem guten anal guten
Erinnerung zweitens bei diesem Krieg der
so unnötig ist der niemals hätte
zustande kommen dürfen in der Ukraine
gegen Russland da geht es um die
Verschiebung von Grenzen da haben sie
völlig Recht die NATO verschiebt ihre
Grenzen seit mehreren Jahrzehnten immer
Richtung Russland und zwar die Nähe der
russischen Grenze
das ist die Wahrheit
zweierweiterungser Wellen die Russen
sind abgezogen beim 2+4 Vertrag sie
verfälschen doch die Geschichte sie
belügen doch die Menschen in unserem
Land die Amerikaner sind nicht abgezogen
sondern die haben ihre Truppen überall
stehen lassen und ausgedehnt machen
nahtloser Erweiterung nach dem anderen
weder amerikanische noch deutsche
Militärstrategen sind überzeugt dass die
Ukraine den Krieg überhaupt gewissen
gewinnen könnte von den Jubelmeldungen
aus der kriegskalenpresse
ist lange nichts mehr zu hören
und jetzt haben wir die Situation dass
selbst in der Ukraine der Widerstand
gegen silensky wächst sie wollen das
nicht wissen sie lesen so was nicht sie
sehen sich auch nicht die Videos an die
man sich nämlich ansehen kann wo
Soldaten
und Feldjäger selenskys durch die
Straßen ziehen und Leute bis ins höhere
Alter verhaften um die an die Truppen in
die Front zu schicken bis 60 Jahre es
ist die siebte oder achte
mobilisierungsfälle die der durchführt
irgendwann kommt jetzt demnächst andere
ran und will Menschen haben dir dort
benutzen kann die USA ich bin jetzt am
Ende jawohl die USA
tun alles um den Krieg zu verlängern es
sterben mehr Russen es sterben mehr Herr
Kollege es tut mir leid ich muss Ihnen
das Wort entziehen aber niemandem ist
gedient mit diesem ich muss ihn wirklich
das Wort entziehen der Kollege Falle sie
ja bedauer das auch sehr aber
die Geschäftsordnung geht auch für sie
so letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte ist der Kollege
Michael Roth SPD-Fraktion und Michael
rot ist Vorsitzender des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses
guten Tag Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Abgeordneter Falle das kann ihn nur
der Kreml aufgeschrieben haben aber das
hat mit der Wirklichkeit und mit der
bitteren Wirklichkeit vor allem für die
Menschen in der Ukraine nichts zu tun
das ist heute liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ein guter Tag für die Menschen
in der Ukraine die seit elf Monaten für
ihre Freiheit für Demokratie für
Souveränität und für ihre territoriale
Integrität kämpfen es ist auch ein guter
Tag für den Zusammenhalt des Bündnisses
zu dem Europa die NATO wir viele andere
Staaten weltweit gehören die seit 11
Monaten an der Seite der Ukraine stehen
und dieses Land das einem grauenhaften
angriffskriegs ausgesetzt ist politisch
wirtschaftlich finanziell aber eben auch
militärisch unterstützen und es ist
zugleich liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ein schlechter Tag für das russische
Regime für den russischen Nationalismus
für den russischen Imperialismus der
Europa und nicht nur die Ukraine in
Angst und Schrecken versetzt hat
ich bin heute morgen gefragt worden ob
ich mich über diese mutige und
weitreichende Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung und des Bundeskanzlers
freue ich freue mich nicht das ist kein
Tag der Freude wir sollten uns liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen freuen wenn
endlich die russischen Truppen sich
vollständig vom ukrainischen
Staatsterritorium zurückgezogen haben
wir dürfen uns freuen wenn endlich die
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
beendet werden wir können uns freuen
wenn es zu einem Waffenstillstand kommen
wir können uns freuen wenn endlich die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer wieder in
Ruhe schlafen können weil sie wissen
dieser Krieg ist beendet wenn Russland
nicht gestoppt wird liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen dann droht in Europa
weiterer Krieg dann sind andere Staaten
beispielsweise auch Moldawien von dem
russischen Imperialismus bedroht deshalb
ist ein Sieg der Ukraine nicht nur ein
der Solidarität gegenüber einem Nachbarn
und eine Partner es liegt auch im
nationalen und im europäischen Interesse
dass dieses Land zu seiner Freiheit und
zu seiner Souveränität zurückfindet
ich gehöre einer Generation an die
geprägt wurde von einem Satz
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen
und ich stehe hier gemeinsam mit vielen
anderen die sagen Frieden schaffen mit
Waffen mehr Waffen bringen uns dem
Frieden näher
und
das erleben wir tagtäglich bei den
Kriegsverbrechen Russlands denn es geht
nicht nur darum dass die Ukraine sich zu
verteidigen mag es geht auch darum dass
die von Russland eroberten Gebiete
befreit werden ob in Butcher oder nipro
wir haben die schlimmsten Verbrechen
erlebt Menschen sind gemäuchelt worden
es wird ein Krieg gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung geführt und deshalb ist
es unsere Pflicht diesen Menschen
engagiert beizustehen und deshalb
brauchen wir Waffen es ist auch ein Akt
der Humanität aber diesen Satz Frieden
schaffen mit mehr Waffen den müssen wir
unserer verängstigten und besorgten
Bevölkerung immer wieder gut erklären
und dabei spielt nicht nur die
Bundesregierung dabei spielen auch wir
als Abgeordnete eine herausragende Rolle
weil wir mit diesen Fragen tagtäglich in
unseren Wahlkreisen oder auch in
Gesprächen in der digitalen Welt
konfrontiert werden
nur wenn Putin verliert ist er wirklich
zu ernsthaften Verhandlungen bereit nur
aus einer Position der Stärke heraus der
militärischen Stärke heraus kann die
Ukraine diesen Krieg beenden das ist in
liberalen Demokratien Streit über den
richtigen Weg geht und wir streiten
darüber wir ringen um das Recht den
richtigen Weg zeichnet und aus und
darauf bin ich auch stolz dass wir das
tun aber wir dürfen uns in diesem
Bündnis für die Ukraine nicht
auseinander dividieren lassen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen sie uns
darauf konzentrieren den russischen
Imperialismus zu bekämpfen damit haben
wir genug zu tun meine Damen und meine
Herren
ein letztes einige scheinen sich in
ihrem ideologischen Sofa so bequem
eingerichtet zu haben dass sie sogar
noch nicht mal vor der Behauptung
zurückschrecken die Ukraine würde
möglicherweise auch den Einsatz von
atomwaffenerwegen da will ich noch mal
auf den Kollegen Uli Lechte zu sprechen
kommen er hat das Budapester memorado
erwähnt
1994 hat die Ukraine ihr komplettes
Atomwaffenarsenal an Russland abgegeben
und dafür gab es eine Beistand
Verpflichtung der USA des Vereinigten
Königreiches und Russland russland hat
diesem Land nicht beigestanden sondern
es hat dieses Land brutalstmöglich
überfallen und was wird zum Schluss
brauchen Sie bitte zum Schluss jetzt
hoffe sie schlussen Botschaft der
Hoffnung für die Ukraine und die kann
nur liegen in einem Platz im vereinigten
Europa der Kollege rot ich habe jetzt
auch das Wort entzogen es nützt nichts
mehr dass sie was sagen weil sie keiner
mehr hören kann also es ist unglaublich
[Applaus]
Bundestagsvizepräsident Wolfgang Kubicki
greift hier durch in diese Aktuellen
Stunde die jetzt ja Ende gefunden hat
mit Michael Roth als letzten Redner
des Abgeordneten rot seine Rede sei wohl
geschrieben worden beleidigt fühlt was
wenn wir darüber nachdenken sollten auch
eher für ihn spricht aber trotzdem der
Kollege sie haben jetzt für 30 Sekunden
das Wort
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident vielen
Dank ich will nur richtig stellen meine
reden schreibe ich selber oder mein
Assistent mit mir zusammen aber niemand
im Kreml und auch nicht sonst wo und ich
weise solche Unterstellungen mit Schärfe
zurück vielen Dank
so damit ist jetzt die Aktuelle Stunde
tatsächlich beendet so das war noch mal
eine persönliche Erklärung von Robert
Falle der hier vor Michael rot
gesprochen hat und damit kommen wir zum
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es
um den Bericht zur auswärtigen Kultur
und Bildungspolitik 2021 also
eine Bilanz der Schwerpunkte des
Koalitionsvertrags der 19 Wahlperiode
also der vorherigen und auch ein
Ausblick auf die neuen Ziele und
Aufgaben die sich die ampelregierung in
der auswärtigen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik gesetzt hat in der
letzten
Legislaturperiode war die Aufarbeitung
des kolonialen Erbes ein wichtiger
Schwerpunkt im letzten Jahr im
vorletzten Jahr schon stand dort die
Diskussion ja zum Beispiel um die
Rückgabe der Benin Branchen ja im Fokus
und eine die sich dafür auch sehr
eingesetzt hat ist unsere
bundesaußenministerin Anna Lena baerbock
und sie hat jetzt auch das erste Wort in
dieser Debatte
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Gäste Niki Diamond aus
Myanmar der als Aktivist vor den
militärsflow und heute in Konstanz
promoviert die kongolesische Professorin
in Tumi die für ihre Verdienste als
infektionsbiologin gefördert von der
Humboldt-Stiftung letztes Jahr das
Bundesverdienstkreuz erhalten hat diese
zwei Menschen sind nur zwei von
hunderten die uns zeigen mit unserer
Kultur und Bildungsarbeit machen wir ein
Unterschied und zwar weltweit
wir schützen die Freiheit von Frauen
Männern und auch Kindern bringen Bildung
und Forschung voran und manchmal
schützen wir damit auch ihr Leib und
Leben der Bericht zur auswärtigen Kultur
und Bildungspolitik über den wir heute
sprechen schaut zurück auf das Jahr 2021
gefühlt ehrlich gesagt eine Ewigkeit her
damals haben wir trinken spaces
beleuchtet wie die Redefreiheit etwa in
Belarus und in vielen anderen Staaten
geschrumpft ist heute müssen wir aber an
vielen Orten längst von disappearing
spaces sprechen
Menschenrechte wie die Pressefreiheit in
Russland werden nicht nur geschrumpft
sie werden weggefegt auch in Iran oder
in Afghanistan
diese brachiale Gewalt ändert auch die
Aufgaben unserer Kultur-
denn unsere auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik auch sie findet nicht im
luftleeren Raum statt sondern auch sie
steht vor den globalen Herausforderungen
eines systemwettbewerbs zwischen
Autokratien und Demokratien
wir wissen Deutschlands Glaubwürdigkeit
und Anziehungskraft sind die Grundlagen
für den Erfolg unserer Außenpolitik und
genau diese Glaubwürdigkeit wird von
anderen in manchen Regionen aber
manchmal auch bei uns im eigenen Haus in
Zweifel gezogen und ja gelegentlich
niedergemacht durch plumpe
disinformation
dem müssen wir uns aktiver als bisher
entgegenstellen
indem wir unbeirrt am Austausch ein
Miteinander von Menschen von Kulturen
mit Gesellschaften dieser Welt
zusammenarbeiten versuchen uns immer
wieder auch in ihre Sichtweise zu setzen
aber auch indem wir uns selber
verständlicher machen
das gilt für uns als Bundesregierung und
das gilt auch für unsere hervorragenden
mittlerorganisationen auslandschulen und
Derad Goethe-Institut Humboldt-Stiftung
und viele mehr
ihr Engagement ist geforderter als
vielleicht nie zuvor
weil Kulturpolitik auch ganz klar
Sicherheitspolitik ist
wenn wir die Freiheit von
Kulturwissenschaft und Medien fördern
dann stärken wir eben damit auch die
Freiheit und die Sicherheit von Menschen
deswegen haben wir mit Blick auf die
heutige Lage Schutzprogramme wie das
Hilde dominenprogramm dessen erster
Stipendiat Niki Diamond aus Myanmar war
ausgebaut wir haben diese Programme zu
dem weiter finanziell aufgestockt da
auch herzlichen Dank an Sie als
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
und zum Beispiel die Hannah Arendt
Initiative für Journalistinnen und
Journalisten neu ins Leben gerufen
wir setzen auf science diplomiss die um
wie im Fall von Professorinnen in Tumi
gemeinsam mit anderen den Kampf gegen
Malaria Tuberkulose und Ebola zu führen
und wir setzen natürlich euch auch
weiter darauf dass 13 Millionen
Schülerinnen und Schüler weltweit
Deutsch lernen weil wir in dieser Welt
Partner brauchen die uns manchmal auch
in unserer eigenen Sprache verstehen
weil wir aber eben auch Fachkräfte und
Wissenschaftlerinnen immer dringender
brauchen weil wir aber auch wissen dass
die Welt vielleicht nicht zuerst
zehnjährige 15-jährige an Deutsch als
erste Fremdsprache denken müssen wir
auch hier unsere auswärtige
Bildungspolitik auf die Höhe der Zeit
bringen indem wir Abschlüsse
konkurrenzfähig ausbauen die Angebote
verbessern gerade auch im Zusammenspiel
mit der Wirtschaft wenn wir unsere
auswärtige Kultur und Bildungspolitik so
gezielt gestalten dann ist sie eben auch
im 21 Jahrhundert kein nice to have dann
ist sie ein essential to have dringend
notwendig weil es um die Menschen geht
ob in der Ukraine Myanmar oder Kongo
weil es um uns geht um Ihre und unsere
gemeinsame Freiheit und Sicherheit in
einer vernetzten Welt herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau bundesaußenministerin
Anna-Lena baerbock war das auf sich
folgt nun Monika Grütters für die
Unionsfraktion momentan Opfer im
Unterausschuss auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik aber sie war auch zweien
2013 bis dezember 2021 Kultur
Staatsministerin Liebe
Kollegen Kunst ist eine Tochter der
Freiheit
schöner als Friedrich Schiller kann man
es kaum sagen und die Aktualität seine
Aussage ist ja in der Tat leider allzu
offensichtlich denn es wirkt in der Tat
liebe Frau bärburg das stimmig ihnen zu
beinahe gespenstisch oder einer
kommunistisch heute hier über einen
Bericht zu zielen Aufgaben und der
Arbeit der auswärtigen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik akwp aus dem Jahr 2021
zu reden wie in der Tat fast wie aus der
Zeit gefahren schon die corona-pandemie
scheint weit weg zu sein dabei hat sie
uns in einer Weise unsere Freiheiten
Schiller im Miteinander genommen wie
kaum zuvor ein anderes geschehen in
dieser Gegenwart vor allem die Kultur
und die kreativen haben darunter
existenziell gelitten und die Kurve
Depression wird bis heute nach und ist
doch schon wieder verdrängt von anderen
krisengeschehen
so gibt der Bericht zur akwp im Jahr
2021 einmal mehr Anlass den
kulturmittlern im Ausland und
hierzulande dafür zu danken
wie wacker
und ideenreich sie den Herausforderungen
dieser Situationen begegnen mit einem so
heißt es zurecht im Bericht großartigen
Maß an Kreativität und Empathie und dass
sie daraus teilweise sogar gestärkt
hervorgegangen sind so zum Beispiel das
Goethe-Institut mit seinen
deutschlehren-programmen immerhin ist
der Anteil der deutschlandlenden
weltweit mittlerweile auf 15,45
Millionen leicht gestiegen die
Entwicklungen Afghanistan und Belarus
haben viele Akteure hier und dort
getroffen und uns einmal mehr gezeigt
dass Freiheit und Demokratie tagtäglich
verteidigt werden müssen überall auf der
Welt und dann immer mehr Orten leider
oft auch hier in Deutschland wie klug
viele Akteure der auswärtigen
Kulturpolitik auf die Herausforderungen
reagieren sehen wir allein an Projekten
nur ein paar Schlagworte wie der
Initiative Fachkräfte Qualifizierung des
Goethe-Instituts vor allem in Südamerika
wie den kulturgutrettern des Deutschen
Archäologischen Institut
erstaunlich finde ich dass der Bericht
sich bei einem für uns so wichtigen Land
wie der Türkei und der großartigen
Kulturakademie Terraria auf lächerliche
sieben Zeilen im knapp 100 Seiten
starken Bericht beschränkt das haben die
Verantwortlichen dort schlicht nicht
verdient
in Zeiten wie diesen in Krisen die nun
seit mehreren Jahren andauern und
zunehmen ist es eine sensibel in die
Zivilgesellschaft hineinwirkende
auswärtige Kulturpolitik wertvoller denn
je umso trauriger ist es dass die
Vorgänger im Auswärtigen Amt ihren
Regierungsentwurf für den Haushalt 2022
mit einem Minus von mehr als zehn
Prozent gegenüber dem Haushalt 21
versehen haben kein guter Staat ins
nächste Krisenjahr es geht auch anders
BKM hatte mehr als zehn Prozent Plus im
Regierungsentwurf wir konnten für dieses
laufende Jahrgang des Parlaments
Schlimmeres für die akwp verhindern möge
es der Ampel eine Lehre sein
Kunst ist eine Tochter der Freiheit das
bestärkt uns in der Überzeugung dass es
sich lohnt in die akwp zu investieren
den mittlern den Rücken zu stärken und
ihre gesellschaftswirksamkeit über den
einzelnen tagesaktuellen kleinen Erfolg
hinweg zu betonen Kultur die sich als
kritisches Korrektiv als lohnender
Standortfaktor vor allem aber als eins
versteht als Ausdruck von Humanität eine
solche Art verstandene Kultur kann zum
Modus des Zusammenlebens werden überall
auf der Welt und ist unser aller
Engagement Wert vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Kutters
als nächste Rednerin hält das Wort die
Kollegin Bettina luck SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die auswärtige
Kultur- und Bildungspolitik ist eines
der nachhaltigsten und vor allen Dingen
auch sichtbarsten Instrumente unserer
Außenpolitik sie hilft dass wir uns
besser untereinander verstehen und das
weltweit dies ist gerade angesichts der
aktuellen Herausforderung wichtiger denn
je und das zeigt dass die akpp weiter
gestärkt werden muss und über
Ressortgrenzen hinaus flexibilisiert
sein muss erst in der vergangenen Woche
hat Bundesminister Heil uns vorgerechnet
wir brauchen sieben Millionen Fachkräfte
bis 2035 und auch wenn wir alle
Potenzial in unserem Land zusammen
gewinnen können reicht es nicht diesen
Fehlbedarf zu decken und darum bin ich
sehr sehr dankbar dass ich meine Stimme
für die akpp heute nutzen kann denn es
ist eben dieser Bereich der den Weg frei
macht für eine Fachkräftegewinnung die
auch noch etwas Wichtiges im Blick
behält nämlich auch Zuwanderung aus dem
Ausland darf nicht dafür sorgen dass in
den Herkunftsländern einfach
kräftemangel entsteht
Institutionen wie das Goethe-Institut
ermöglichen durch ihre Programme
Zuwanderung von qualifizierten und vor
allen Dingen auch motivierten
Fachkräften beispielsweise aus
Lateinamerika dank der Kurse die
angeboten werden sie auf das Leben und
die Arbeit in Deutschland vorbereitet
und erlernen bereits im Ausland die
deutsche Sprache und das befähigt sie
auch
zukünftig legal zuzuwandern in ähnlicher
Weise tragen auch deutsche außenschulen
dazu bei Fachkräfte für unter anderem
für unsere heimischen Betriebe zu
gewinnen
sie für unser Land zu begeistern Anreize
nach Deutschland zu kommen sie sind
definitiv da und das ist unsere Aufgabe
durch ein modernes Einwanderungsgesetz
Zugangskriterien für qualifizierte
Einwanderer zu lockern
denn Fachkräfte Sicherung ist auch
wohlstandssicherung und die akpp bleibt
daher auch in Zukunft eine wichtiger
Säule unserer außen und das besonders
wichtig unserer Friedenspolitik an
dieser Stelle möchte ich auch gerne noch
einen kurzen Blick auf den Sport werfen
denn die niederschwelligen Angebote im
Sport durch diese Angebote gelingt es
der akpp Kinder und Jugendliche in feste
Strukturen zu binden sport trägt extrem
wirkungsvoll dazu bei Perspektiven und
auch Lebensbedingungen zu verbessern und
gerade Perspektiven schaffen es hier das
Stichwort unser Anteil an der Erreichung
entwicklungspolitischer Ziele besteht im
Sport auch darin Trainerinnen und
Trainer Lehrer und Sozialarbeiter
weiterzubilden genauso schaffen
Investitionen Infrastrukturprojekte die
Grundvoraussetzungen für den Zugang zu
einem pädagogischen Sport Angebot die
qualitativ hochwertigen Sportprojekte
die durch die akpp gefördert werden
fördern Bildung Frieden Gewaltprävention
dienen der Gleichstellung der
Geschlechter und fördern die Gesundheit
und dies wiederum trägt dazu bei dass
wir friedlicher zusammenleben können in
einer internationalen Gemeinschaft
durch die ergriffenen perspekt
Initiativen die sich durch die akpp
ergeben spielt die AKP aktiv bei der
großen Zukunftsfrage mit Investition in
eine gestaltende Außenpolitik bringen
uns innen aber auch außen voran die
Haushaltsmittel sind in der auswärtigen
Kultur und Bildungspolitik nachhaltig
und effektiv eingesetzt und wir hörten
vorhin schon den Dank der Kolleginnen
wir danken natürlich unseren Kolleginnen
und Kollegen unseren mittlerorganisation
die einen unverzichtbaren Beitrag
leisten dass wir für unser Land aber
auch für unsere Partnerländer ein
beispielhaftes Projekt haben vielen Dank
dafür
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Bettina Lücke
war das für die SPD-Fraktion und nun
spricht für die afd-fraktion Matthias
mosdorf er ist für seine Fraktion ob man
im Unterausschuss auswärtige Kultur- und
Bildungspolitik investiert viel Geld in
eine neue überarbeitete Sicht auf sich
selbst dabei sind unsere Geschichte
unsere Werte und Errungenschaften
einzigartig oft Vorbild für andere
Kulturen und Gesellschaften weltweit die
Zahl der deutschen Welterbestätten
übersteigt die alle anderen Länder
beträchtlich auch das Modell unseres
Zusammenlebens recht Demokratie soziale
Sicherheit war oft beispielgebend was
wir jedoch kommunizieren hat
paradoxerweise wer mit Schuld und
Selbstverleugnung zu tun bis hin zur
Aufgabe der eigenen Verfasstheit zu
Gunst in eines fragwürdigen
europa-modells dabei ist es doch gerade
unser bewegter und gewachsener Kontinent
ein Beispiel für Vielfalt und streben
Heimat und Kultur sind natürlich und
nationale Herzensangelegenheiten keine
Zukunft ohne Herkunft einige Anmerkungen
zum Bericht bei der völlig sinnvollen
Aufarbeitung unseres kolonalen Erbes
dürfen wir nicht verkennen dass viele
zivilisatorischen marktsteine noch heute
Orientierung bieten Kooperationen sind
viel nachhaltiger als einmalige
symbolakte von gesinnungsethischer
Wiedergutmachung rückgaben sind ein
deutscher Sonderweg frankreich hat nach
blumiger Ankündigung macrons genau zwei
Werke restituiert der britis Museum Act
verbietet solche Handlungen sogar
dauerhaft bei der Unterstützung von
afghanischen ortskräften sollte der
Schwerpunkt auf der örtlichen Hilfe
liegen laut Antwort der Bundesregierung
auf eine kleine Anfrage ist über eine
systematische Verfolgung von ehemaligen
ortskräften nichts bekannt wenn die
Außenministerin alle Frauen als
verfolgte sieht ist diese Politik
wahnsinnig denn es gibt deren zehn
Millionen
das Goethe-Institut Tel Aviv betreibt
öffentlich Arm und Arm mit der
Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung linke Propaganda
im Ausland der Vorsitzende der
Gedenkstätte jagdwaschem embörte sich
über eine Verharmlosung des judenmords
am Gedenktag an die Novemberpogrome 1938
Zitat hat man beschlossen die Erinnerung
an den Holocaust zu verharmlosen und das
ausgerechnet in Israel und mit deutschem
Steuergeld das ist inakzeptabel und
respektlos
wenn wir Werte vertreten dann bitte ohne
ein Auge zuzudrücken der Bericht beklagt
verkleinerte Räume für Kultur schaffende
ja richtig die gibt es auch hier wie
viele Konzerte von Musikern mit
russischen Namen wurden dann abgesagt in
der Ukraine landeten im letzten Sommer
sogar russische Musik und Literatur als
feind-propaganda auf dem Index nachdem
man im März schon 11 Oppositionen
Parteien verboten hatte die Medien
gleichgeschaltet und das freie Wort
unter Strafe gestellt Stichwort Werte
die Handhabung der Rückgabe von Kunst
aus der
ns-inquisition von 1.500 beschlagnahmen
Werten des Sammlers Cornelius waren nur
14 Werke zu beanstanden die Hexenjagd
von Behörden und Medien haben ihn
trotzdem in den Tod getrieben
lasst uns aufhören mit der Belehrung der
Welt sind unsere Werte gut werden sie
sich durchsetzen im Moment schwindet
dieser Zuspruch alle
gesellschaftsprojekte Energiewende
Elektromobilität Multikulti
Willkommenskultur Euro und Klimarettung
sind fast ohne Bezug zur Machbarkeit und
Realität geplant schon unsere
unmittelbaren Nachbarn folgen uns nicht
von dem Rest der Welt nicht zu reden
eine Werte basierte Außenpolitik fliegt
uns überall um die Ohren die
selbstbewusste afghanische
Zivilgesellschaft ist ein menetikel ihre
völlig verzerrten Wahrnehmung im
weltweiten Ranking der besten
Universitäten hingeben tauchen wir gar
nicht mehr auf die Bildung Basis unseres
Ansehens in der Welt schwindet
von einem Land welches über Jahrhunderte
Geschichte geschrieben hat rutschen wir
in die Beobachterrolle
liebe Kollegen wer wenn nicht wir können
all diese trugenden in die Welt tragen
denken und Meinung brauchen Offenheit
keine schablonen von Gefolgschaft wir
müssen zu einer normalen Politik
zurückfinden besonders im Fundament von
Bildung und Kultur letzter Satz
pragmatisch respektvoll auch gegenüber
anderen Lebensmodellen als den
westlichen heimat ist dort wo man sich
nicht erklären muss daraus erwächst die
Kraft hier wie überall diese multipolare
Welt
wollen wir erhalten vielen Dank
Matthias im Moosdorf war das für die
afd-fraktion hier in der Debatte zum
Bericht zur auswärtigen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik 2021 Thomas Hacker hat
nun das Wort erste medienpolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dem ersten Kanzler unserer
Bundesrepublik Konrad Adenauer werden
folgende Worte zugeschrieben die
Methoden einer Außenpolitik können sich
schon einmal ändern aber das vertrauen
ist die Basis es darf nicht angetastet
werden Vertrauen ist einfach
entscheidend
einem Land wieder zu vertrauen das
verantwortlich war für ein barbadischen
Krieg für millionenfachen Mord für den
absoluten Zivilisationsbruch Chino vier
Jahre nach dem Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs für viele Länder unmöglich
und doch es ist gelungen Aufarbeitung
nennt man das Herr mussdorf in den
letzten sieben Jahrzehnten hat unser
Land weltweit Vertrauen zurückgewonnen
mehr noch wir haben Freunde gewonnen und
das wäre ohne die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik so nicht möglich gewesen
die dritte Säule der Außenpolitik bringt
Menschen in aller Welt mit uns zusammen
sie trägt unsere Kulturen unsere Sprache
in die Welt sie sucht und findet das
gemeinsame und überwindet so Barrieren
der 25 Bericht zur auswärtlichen Kultur
und Bildungspolitik den wir heute hier
diskutieren ist die Fortschreibung einer
Erfolgsgeschichte es ist keine große
Auflistung von einzelnen Maßnahmen
sondern eine Zwischenbilanz in welchen
nachhaltigen Netzwerken und starken
Partnerschaften wir arbeiten in denen
Vertrauen in den letzten Jahrzehnten
weiter und wieder gewachsen ist Stück
für Stück ein Vertrauen das gerade in
diesen herausfordernden Zeiten nicht den
Zweifel gezogen wird und dass ein
belastbares Fundament für die
Herausforderungen unserer Gegenwart und
Zukunft ist etablierte Schutzprogramme
wie die Philipp schwarze Initiative der
Alexander von Humboldt-Stiftung oder das
Hilde dominenprogramm draußen
waren entscheidend dafür dass wir nach
dem Beginn des russischen angriffskriegs
sofort Hilfe leisten konnten
mit Hilfe für hunderte forschende
Künstlerinnen und Künstler Studierende
sowie Medien schaffen denn den dieser
Krieg von hier auf jetzt die
Lebensgrundlage entzogen hat in der
Ampel bekennen wir uns zu den
unerschütterlichen Netzwerken die
vergangene Bereinigungssitzung des
Haushaltsausschuss hat das mit der
ampelmehrheit liebe Monika Grütters
bewiesen trotz einer schwierigen
Haushaltssituation sparen wir nicht bei
unseren Organisationen im Gegenteil wir
setzen zur Vermittlung unserer
wir setzen zur Vermittlung unserer
werteorientierten Außenpolitik auf die
akbg und stärken sie das bedeutet aber
auch notwendige Reformen
angesichtsveränderter globaler
Realitäten nicht zu scheuen wie die
maßgabebeschluss zum Haushalt 23 für das
Goethe-Institut haben wir diesen
Reformprozess nun bei unserer größten
mittlerorganisation angestoßen den
Prozess werden wir im Deutschen
Bundestag eng begleiten das Bild der PP
als dritter Säule unserer Außenpolitik
darf aber auch nicht falsch verstanden
werden sich nicht sie ist nicht isoliert
sondern sie muss voll integrierter
Bestandteil unserer Sicherheitsstrategie
sein lassen Sie mich an einem Beispiel
erläutert warum das so wichtig ist im
Dezember 22 wurden im Rahmen eines
Hackerangriffs auf die größte russische
Fernsehgesellschaft erstmals Dokumente
öffentlich die die bilaterale
Zusammenarbeit von Russland und China
bei der Verbreitung von Desinformationen
und Verschwörungstheorien enthüllen und
diese wirken ja
das Ziel von Kino und Russland ist klar
demokratische Gesellschaften sollen von
innen geschwächt werden diese Angriffe
auf unsere Werte auf unsere Gesellschaft
auf unsere Überzeugungen werden wir
nicht zulassen
dem autoritären Blog müssen wir auch
starke Werte Vermittler wie die Deutsche
Welle gegenüberstellen Mittler die
unsere Ideale einer freien und
vielfältigen Kultur in die Welt tragen
den Wettbewerb mit einem systemrivalen
wieder Volksrepublik China kann die
Bundesrepublik nicht alleine bestehen
wir müssen europäisch denken Synergien
nutzen und zu einer europäischen
Arbeitsteilung kommen die
Grundsteinlegung für das
deutsch-französische Kulturinstitut in
Erbil am vergangenen Sonntag ist dabei
ein starkes Zeichen
deutsch-französischer Freundschaft und
ein wichtiger Schritt in der
europäischen Zusammenarbeit mehr müssen
folgen
die weltweite Zusammenarbeit der
Bildungs- und Kulturpolitik hat aber
auch für unsere Wirtschaft und
Wissenschaft einen ganz konkreten Nutzen
als Exportnation profitieren wir vom
positiven Bild unseres Landes Menschen
die zu uns kommen um unsere Wirtschaft
zu stärken helfen unserem Land es ist
gut dass der Sprachunterricht des
Goethe-Instituts Eingang in die
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
gefunden hat und im
wissenschaftsnetzwerk der Alexander von
Humboldt-Stiftung arbeiten mittlerweile
30.000 humboldtianer aus 140 Ländern
zusammen darunter 59 Nobelpreisträger
das stärkt unsere Wissenschaftsstandort
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die akbib
bringt Menschen und Märkte zusammen baut
Vertrauen auf unterstützt Demokratie
schafft
freiheits-organisationen weltweit die
danke für ihren Einsatz und ihre
Leistung und danke Herr Präsident und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen zugehört
haben
Thomas Hacker war das für die
FDP-Fraktion hat hier unter anderem das
Goethe-Institut erwähnt das ursprünglich
in diesem Jahr nur mit
219,9 Millionen Euro rechnen konnte
allerdings wurde diese Etat dann
angehoben auf 235 Millionen Euro sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren meine Fraktion
möchte allen Menschen danken die im
Innen- und Ausland Kultur und Bildung
vermitteln sie machen eine großartige
Arbeit
nun wollte aber die Bundesregierung für
den Haushalt 2023 die Aktie bei der
auswärtigen Kultur und Bildungspolitik
anlegen das Gehörte Institut musste zum
Beispiel Fortbildungsprogramme für
Deutschlehrer zusammenstreichen dieser
Akt der Kulturlosigkeit wurde im
Haushaltsausschuss gestoppt das war eine
gute und richtige Entscheidung meine
Damen und Herren es ging es ging
insgesamt um 55 Millionen Euro und die
gekürzt werden sollten zum Vergleich ein
einziger Lenkflugkörper für den
Atombomber
f35a kostet 2,6 Millionen Euro die
Bundesregierung will davon 150 kaufen
das macht
272 Millionen Euro und das
Goethe-Institut mit seinen 158
Instituten in 98 Ländern bekommen in
diesem Jahr 239 Euro ich frage sie was
hilft der Menschheit mehr im Kampf um
Frieden Demokratie und
Völkerverständigung die Antwort ist für
uns lieber mehr Goethe als diese
tödliche Teufelszeug meine Damen und
Herren und Kultur Kultur soll helfen
Konflikten vorzubeugen Wandel anzustoßen
Demokratie und Werte zu fördern Willy
Brandt sprach von der Arbeit an der Welt
Vernunft und wer bei Kultur und Bildung
kürzen will behindert die Arbeit an der
Welt Vernunft der Haushaltsausschuss hat
also entschieden die Mittel für
auswärtige Kultur und Bildung nicht zu
kürzen sondern aufzustocken und das war
ein Sieg der Vernunft in diesem
Bundestag meine Damen und Herren doch es
gibt immer noch ein gravierendes Problem
die auswärtige Kulturpolitik soll für
Werte stehen aber die europäische
Abschottung ist das Gegenteil der oft
beschworenen Dialogbereitschaft die
Wirtschaftspolitik interessiert sich für
Menschenrechte nur im ausnahmefelden der
Bremer Ethnologe Jens Adam fragt ob
Zitat die Bilder von kreativen
Begegnungen zufriedenen Jugendlichen
oder kosmopolitischen Kulturschaffenden
in urbanen Kontexten die die auswärtige
Kulturpolitik hervorbringt nicht
Feigenblätter sind wir sagen Ihnen wir
brauchen keine Feigenblätter wer Mauern
um Europa baut der will kein Dialog und
wer die Rettung von Menschen im
Mittelmeer aktiv verhindert der sollte
nicht von Menschenrechten reden meine
Damen und Herren und vor aligarchen vor
arabischen Oligarchen überhaupt keinen
Oligarchen macht man einen Diener auch
das entspricht nicht unseren Werten
meine Damen und Herren das Ziel von
Völkerverständigung muss immer der
Frieden sein dafür brauchen wir eine
starke auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik und wir brauchen keine
Waffenexporte in Krisengebiete vielen
Dank meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank soweit gesünder Lötsch für
die linke und arbeitest für Jesus hat
nun eine Minute Redezeit für die Grünen
Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kollegin rero 1 ihrer Trachten
aufzwacken ich erzählte ihn von meiner
Klassenfahrt zum British Museum und
meiner eigenen Suche nach meinem
kulturellen Erbe die Enttäuschung hat
sich in den Ausstellungsräumen nichts
fand ich wusste nicht dass das meiste in
den Archiven liegt unzugänglich für die
Öffentlichkeit
auswärtige Kultur und Bildungspolitik
ist keine reine Außenpolitik klare
Trennlinien zwischen wir hier und die da
drüben werden immer fließender wenn wir
heute über Rückgabe von Raubkunst
sprechen dann auch weil die Diaspora
sich hier seit Jahrzehnten dafür
eingesetzt hat wenn Annalena baerbock
und Claudia Roth nach Nigeria reisen um
gestohlene benebrancen zurückzugeben
dann findet Aussöhnung und Heilung nicht
nur in Nigeria Stadt sondern auch hier
bei uns und ein Stück weit auch bei mir
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
als nächster das Wort der Kollege Thomas
Rachel cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Welt ist im
Umbruch die Herausforderungen für die
auswärtige Kultur- und Bildungspolitik
ist gerade seit dem Überfall Russland
auf die Ukraine gestiegen dabei ist die
Zusammenarbeit über Grenzen hinweg
notwendiger denn je die Bundesregierung
unter Angela Merkel war weitsichtig hat
gehandelt und die Bedeutung der
auswärtigen Kultur und Bildungspolitik
gesehen und hat sie gestärkt ich denke
an die Unterstützung der Kultur
Milliarde ich denke an die Unterstützung
von DHD Goethe-Institut der
Humboldt-Stiftung den Auslandsschulen
aber auch die Max weber-institute im
Ausland oder die Schutzprogramme für die
Flüchtlinge und schließlich auch science
diplomacy wo wir die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Hochschulen und Wissenschaft
aufgebaut haben
Deutschland will Verantwortung in der
Welt übernehmen das meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren gelingt nicht ohne
Dialog nicht ohne wissenschaftlichen
Austausch und Partnerschaften die
Vermittlung demokratischer Werte geht
nicht ohne internationalen Austausch
Auswärtige Kulturpolitik ist in diesem
Sinne nach meinem Verständnis auch ein
Stück Friedensarbeit
ich möchte an der Stelle ausdrücklich
positiver hervorheben die Übergaben der
gestohlenen Branchen durch die
bundesaußenministerin Frau bärburg und
ich kann verweisen auf die
Zusammenarbeit auch mit der vorigen
Regierung mit Monika grüters die dieses
mit vorbereitet hat aber es gibt auch
Dinge die mich nachdenklich machen ist
nicht im Koalitionsvertrag der neuen
ampelregierung ein bisschen vollmundig
von
die Rede davon ich zitiere wir stärken
die Religion und die Außenpolitik in
Gegenteil dieser Bereich verliert an
Bedeutung noch im Jahr 2019 wurde die
zehnte weltversammlung der religions for
peace in Lindau durchgeführt mit dem
friedensdialog der Weltreligion ein ganz
wichtiges Thema
unabhängig jetzt von technischen und
finanziellen Aspekten ist denn der
politische Wille der Bundesregierung
sich für solche hochrangigen religiöse
treffen einzusetzen überhaupt zu
erkennen ich glaube eher nein
das Referat Religion und Außenpolitik im
Auswärtigen Amt wird zunehmend
geschwächt es dürfen künftig keine
religiösen Vertreter mehr auf
Vertragsbasis als Berater eingestellt
werden erhöht das nicht
erhöht das etwa die Kenntnis über
religiöse Dimensionen von Konflikten
wohl kaum und lassen Sie mich
abschließend ansprechen ein anderes
Beispiel der Schwächung das ist die
verfügte Schließung des
dhd-informationszentrum in Vietnam dies
steht im diametralen Widerspruch zu der
indopazifikleitlinien der
Bundesregierung wo es um die
Intensivierung dieser Beziehungen geht
das verstößt gegen unsere elementaren
Interessen der Gewinnung von Fachkräften
gerade aus der Pflege was wir mit
Vietnam hervorragend auf den Weg
gebracht haben
meine Damen und Herren mit diese
Veränderungen müssen meines Erachtens
überdacht werden und korrigiert werden
sonst wird den Interessen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland geschadet
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Thomas rachel
hat hier gesagt Auswärtige Kulturpolitik
ist Friedensarbeit und hat natürlich
auch auf den
religionsdialog verwiesen er ist auch
Kirchen und religionspolitischer
Sprecher seiner Fraktion
herr Präsident werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Überwindung von
wissensgrenzen hängt oft auch von der
Überwindung nationaler Grenzen ab
Wissenschaft und Forschung sind schon
seit Jahrhunderten international
organisiert und deswegen macht es ihnen
von der rechten Seite wahrscheinlich
auch so viel Angst weil sie gar nicht
mehr wissen was eigentlich in der
Wissenschaft nationale Errungenschaften
sind weil es bei der Nobelpreisen zum
Beispiel von Frau davon Herrn um
wissenschaftliche Leistung geht die hier
in Deutschland erbracht wurden sind sie
aber in einem großen internationalen
Kontext stattfinden ich finde das
richtig gut
aber internationale Wissenschaft ist
keine Selbstverständlichkeit ihre
Bedingungen müssen neu verhandelt werden
ihre Institutionen müssen jederzeit
wieder neu ausgerichtet und gestärkt
werden und deswegen bin ich froh dass
wir heute diesen Bericht zur auswärtigen
Kultur und Bildungspolitik noch einmal
debattieren jede zweite
englischsprachige Publikation der
deutschen Hochschule hat mittlerweile
eine internationale Kuratorin oder einen
internationalen Co-Autor Deutschland ist
in vielen internationalen
großforschungsprojekten präsent die
deutsche Wissenschaft profitiert von der
Globalisierung und doch müssen wir bei
all diesen Erfolgsmeldungen sagen
natürlich war die zeitenwände der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
eine Zäsur und diese Zensur macht uns
noch mal deutlich wie stark wir auch
wissenschafts- sind wie stark wir Schutz
derjenigen Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler brauchen die in ihren
Ländern verfolgt werden die Weltkrieg
fliehen müssen übrigens in Syrien in
Afghanistan in der Ukraine und jetzt
auch wenn wir über das Thema Iran reden
wir brauchen diesen Schutz dieser
Wissenschaftlerinnen in Deutschland und
wir brauchen dafür im übrigen auch nicht
das nächste Sonderprogramm und das
übernächste Sonderprogramm sondern wir
müssen gemeinsam daran arbeiten die
mittlerorganisationen zu stärken einen
funktionierenden verlässlichen
Schutzmechanismus aufzubauen und wir
müssen in den Ländern dafür sorgen dass
Deutsche mittlerorganisation
leuchttürmer sind für freie Wissenschaft
und Inseln der Wissenschaftsfreiheit in
diesen Ländern aufbauen
wir leben in einer globalisierten Welt
und wir wollen das auch gar nicht ändern
wir wollen globale Wissenschaft
erleichtern und ermöglichen wir brauchen
einen funktionierenden Forschungsraum
und wir brauchen eine funktionierende
Wissenschaft Zusammenarbeit übrigens
auch mit Afrika Asien und Teilen
Lateinamerikas das hat auch etwas mit
wissenschaftsaußenpolitik zu tun das
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
in diesen Ländern übrigens nicht nur
Partner aus China finden sondern auch
solche die die Freiheit von Wissenschaft
betonen Kooperation müssen dem
Fortschritt dienen sie müssen den
Fortschritt der Menschen in den
Mittelpunkt stellen sie dürfen nicht
globale Hierarchien zementieren und sie
dürfen auch nicht autoritäre Regime
stützen wir müssen deshalb unsere
Maßstäbe klar definieren deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir die institutionell
Zusammenarbeit mit Russland beendet
haben und unsere Zusammenarbeit mit
China neu Austritt wir müssen jetzt
gemeinsam definieren wo wir mit wem
kooperieren
welche Beantwortung wir dafür übernehmen
als Politik und welche Ziele weder
mitverfolgen dafür braucht es eine klare
Ressortabstimmung bei dem Thema
außenwissenschaftspolitik dafür braucht
es eine klare Stärkung der Institutionen
die dafür Verantwortung tragen der ARDS
und der Alexander von Humboldt-Stiftung
aber auch zum Beispiel der
max-weber-stiftung die mit den Deutschen
Historischen Instituten im Ausland eine
enorm wichtige Arbeit leistet alles
andere wäre ein Fehler liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen vielen Dank
Robert Stüwe war das für die
Sozialdemokraten hier im aktuellen
Bericht bzw im Bericht zum Jahr 2021 zur
auswärtigen Kultur und Bildungspolitik
der nach dieser Debatte an die
entsprechenden Ausschüsse überwiesen
wird Susanne Hirsch spricht nun für die
Unionsfraktion
der herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte den Blick auf die
deutschen Auslandsschulen und deren
Bedeutung für den Erwerb der deutschen
Sprache Linken im Jahr 2021 gab es 136
anerkannte deutsche Auslandsschulen in
75 Ländern es wurden ca 85.000 Schüler
beschult davon 60.000 nicht deutsche
Herkunft daneben gibt es mit dem
pass-netzwerk weltweit mehr als 1900
Schulen an welchen Deutsch eine
besonderen hohen Stellenwert hat zum
einen wird Deutsch als fremdsprachige
fördert aber zugleich entsteht
Verständnis für eine andere Kultur und
das Interesse auf Deutschland wird
geweckt mehr als 600.000 Schülerinnen
und Schüler profitieren von dem Programm
und erlangen die deutsche Sprachdiplom
die letzte Bundesregierung hat diese
erkannt und hat die deutschen
Auslandsschulen als Chance für die
fachkräfteeinwanderung gesehen daher war
es Ziel die Schulen weiterzuentwickeln
und zukunftsfähig zu machen die Mittel
für die Schulen sind in den letzten
Jahren stetig aufgewachsen zum ersten
dritten 2020 trat das Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz in Kraft für eine
gute Integration und Zuwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt ist die Kenntnis der
deutschen Sprache essentiell damit
gewinnt Deutsch als Fremdsprache und die
hier bestehenden Programme weiter an
Bedeutung wir haben mit dem deutschen
Auslandsschulen und dem passnetzwerk die
notwendige Infrastruktur und die
Möglichkeiten die Fachkräfte von morgen
schon früh für Deutschland zu begeistern
Ihnen die Sprache näher zu bringen und
gegebenenfalls eine Ausbildung in
unserem dialen System zu ermöglichen
diese bereits bestehenden Ressourcen
spielen in der Debatte der Ampel zum
Fachkräftemangel kaum eine Rolle auch
das IDW stellt das in einer
Stellungnahme aus dem dezember 2022 fest
auch die aktuelle Bundesregierung hat im
Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt den aus das
auslandsschulnetz und das
taschennetzwerk doch einen Masterplan
weiter zu entwickeln auch in der
fachkräftestrategie findet sich das
push-netzwerk ein Netzwerk wieder nicht
aber explizit die deutschen
Auslandsschulen dabei bieten doch gerade
diese nicht nur die Möglichkeit alle
deutschen Schulabschlüsse bis hin zum
Abitur abzulegen was auch zum Studium in
Deutschland berechtigt deutsche
Auslandsschulen bieten darüber hinaus
auch duale Ausbildungen nach deutschem
Vorbild statt nun vor dem Hintergrund
des bestehenden Fachkräftemangels diese
bestehenden Strukturen zu stärken kürzt
die Ampel die Mittel für die deutschen
Auslandsschulen um 4 Millionen Euro und
plant die Stellen für die
Prozessbegleiter an den Auslandsschulen
drastisch zu streichen
damit liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Ampel setzen Sie sich in Widerspruch zu
ihrem eigenen Koalitionsvertrag und den
Aussagen ihrer
fachkräfteeinwanderungsstrategie
wenn es ihnen wirklich ernst ist und ihr
Auslandsschulen für sie einen wichtigen
Bestandteil der Fachkräfte Einwanderung
darstellen dann stärken Sie diese Stadt
die Mittel zu kürzen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Susanne hier war das
und damit kommen wir zur letzten
Rednerin in dieser Debatte Michelle
Müntefering war März 2018 bis dezember
2021 Staatsministerin für internationale
Kulturpolitik
mitten im Winter habe ich erfahren dass
es in mir einen unbesiegbaren Sommer
gibt das schreibt Albert Camus in
Heimkehr aus tipasa über den
Sehnsuchtsort sondern noch unbeschwerten
Jugend ohne zu glauben er könnte die
vergangene Zeit wieder zum Leben
erwecken Sommer und Licht sein die
wichtigsten Worte seines Werkes sagt er
später die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik über die wir jetzt
sprechen ist das Licht und der Sommer im
tiefen Winter der Außenpolitik und wir
brauchen ihren gesamten
Instrumentenkasten fernab auch der
großen Diplomatie von Jugend debattiert
der deutsch-türkischen jugendbrücke bis
zum geplanten Sommercamp des jungen
Forums der deutsche israelischen
Gesellschaft wir brauchen auch diese
Programme gerade für eine junge
Generation die in der Pandemie vieles
nicht erleben konnte was uns sonst
selbstverständlich scheint und jetzt
Krieg in Europa gestern Abend erzählte
mir ein Freund von der ersten Liebe
seines 12-jährigen Sohnes der sich große
Sorgen macht um die Familie seiner
kleinen Freundin die noch in der Ukraine
ist liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
müssen gerade jetzt ermöglichen was
Grundlage allen Zusammenlebens ist ein
gutes Miteinander und die akbp die kann
das und die tut das und vieles mehr in
einer Zeit in den Fake News Meinung
machen fördert sie die Ausbildung von
Journalistinnen gibt geflüchteten
Menschenrechtlern Schutz setzt auf
Unterstützung der Wissenschaft und in
Dialog mit dem globalen Süden ermöglicht
Fachkräften in ihren Heimatländern das
Erlernen der deutschen Sprache wir haben
es heute morgen erst im Ausschuss gehört
sie bildet an Auslandsschulen junge
Menschen aus sie vergibt Stipendien und
erhält das kulturelle Welt Erbe
der akbp-jahresbericht 21 ist dabei in
der Tat Blick in Vergangenheit aber auch
in Zukunft zugleich wir können nicht in
die alte Zeit zurück und wir können
nicht genau sagen wie die Welt in zwei
Jahren aussieht aber wir dürfen nicht
aufhören auch mitten in der Zeitenwende
mitten im Winter die Sonne zu suchen die
gute Nachricht der Bericht zeigt auch
wie viele sich hier engagieren ob alte
oder neue Regierung BMBF BKM BMZ das
Familienministerium bis natürlich hin
zum federführenden Auswärtigen Amt von
all den Organisationen des
Goethe-Instituts der AvH des IFA der
UNESCO dem dai den Auslandsschulen der
Deutschen Welle als Vorsitzende im
Unterausschuss möchte ich mich heute bei
ihnen allen bedanken und ich hoffe dass
ich das auch im Namen aller
demokratischen Parteien hier im
Bundestag tun darf das Vertrauen dass
Deutschland in der Welt genießt das ist
auch ihr
Verdienst herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Münze Ferien
damit schließe ich die Aussprache
und damit wird der Bericht an den
Auswärtigen Ausschuss überwiesen und da
dann auch noch weiter debattiert wir
kommen hier zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt die Unionsfraktion
hat einen Antrag eingereicht mit dem
Titel Belarus in die europäische
Völkerfamilie zurückführen den
freiheitsfilm der Menschen unterstützen
und in diesem Antrag fordert die
Unionsfraktion mehrere Maßnahmen um eben
das
zu schaffen unter anderem möchte sie das
ist Sanktionen härter und gezielter
gegen die Angehörigen des
Sicherheitsapparates von Präsident
Alexander Lukaschenko gibt und für die
Unionsfraktion spricht nun als erstes
Knut Abraham
vielen Dank herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
eigentlich viel zu selten von Belarus
gut dass wir es heute tun dabei liegt
das Land mitten in Europa dort
entspringt die Memel ein Fluss von
großer Bedeutung in der europäischen
Geschichte und die Belarussen sind
Europäer wie wir wie die ihren die denen
oder die Samen
nie ist mir das deutlicher geworden als
im Sommer der Hoffnung des Jahres 2020
in Belarus als Tausende junger benerosen
auch vor den Botschaften ihres Landes
standen um an den Wahlen teilzunehmen
von sehen von denen sie bereits
befürchten mussten dass sie massiv
gefälscht werden würden ich habe damals
mit diesen jungen Leuten gesprochen das
waren in Warschau wo viele tausend
Belarussen studieren und von einem leben
in einem freien Land als Teil des freien
Europa träumen so wie sie es in ihrem
Alltag in Polen sehen
doch Belarus wird seit den
grotesken-wahlfälschung weiter von einem
komplett
illegitim Machthaber regiert gestützt
auf das Moskauer Regime unterdrückte die
Freiheitsbewegung drangsaliert die
nationalen Minderheiten vor allem die
polnische und Kerker tausende ein die
wenigen entlassenen berichten von
barbarischen Haftbedingungen grauenvoll
auch wie das Regime des Lukaschenka
migrantenmissbrauch
t an all dem wird sich leider
kurzfristig nicht verändern Moskau wird
lukaschenker weiter stützen denn Belarus
spielt für Russland eine enorm wichtige
Rolle als Aufmarschgebiet gegen die
Ukraine von dort aus wird die Ukraine
bedroht und beschossen aber auch für den
Transit von Russland in dessen
Territorium um die Stadt Königsberg die
auf polnisch Kohle wie jetzt und auf
Litauisch heißt und den traurigen
russischen Namen Kaliningrad trägt
was können wir tun das wichtigste liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist Belarus
Aufmerksamkeit zu geben Polen tut das in
vorbildlicher Weise überhaupt hat Polen
eine regional äußerst aktive Politik das
ist gut so dass Deutschland in
Mittelosteuropa durch die Politik der
Bundesregierung in eine selbst
geschaffene Riesenlücke gefallen ist
wir hier im Bundestag schaffen heute mit
dieser der Werte übrigens auf unsere
Initiative Aufmerksamkeit für Belarus
und dazu habe ich fünf Botschaften
zunächst eine Botschaft eines
belarussische Volk Liebe Belarussen
Liebe europäische Landsleute gibt die
Hoffnung nicht auf jedes Regime hat mal
ein Ende und dann ist es eure
Entscheidung wie ihr euer Land gestaltet
und eine Botschaft an die Peter
russische Opposition seit einig nur dann
seid ihr stark im Land unimexil und es
ist ganz klar es wird leider nicht Geier
hat die Wahlen gewonnen da hat daher hat
sie und nur sie eine einzigartige
Legitimität von der Bevölkerung erhalten
sie ist die zentrale Leitfigur und dann
habe ich eine Botschaft an diejenigen
parat die Verantwortung für ihr Land und
dessen Bürger empfinden und die wissen
dass ihr Staatspräsident ohne
Legitimität regiert beteiligen sie sich
nicht an den Repressionen werden sie
nicht mitschuldig helfen sie so gut sie
können den bedrängen
und ich habe eine Botschaft an die
Folterknechte seien Sie gewiss man kennt
ihre Namen ihre Verbrechen und die ihrer
Vorgesetzten werden dokumentiert und sie
werden angeklagt werden
hier steht jetzt Pause denn jetzt komme
ich zur Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung kann viel mehr tun sogar
sehr viel mehr denn es fehlt oberhalb
des Engagements der deutschen Botschaft
in Minsk und den Bemühungen der
Diplomaten auf Arbeitsebene die zentrale
politische Ansprechperson bis zum
Antritt dieser Bundesregierung gab es
einen Koordinator mit der wichtigen wer
noch etwas sperrigen Bezeichnung
Koordinator für die zwischen
gesellschaftliche Zusammenarbeit mit
Russland Zentralasien und den Länder der
Östlichen Partnerschaft unser viel zu
früh verstorbener Kollege Andreas
Schockenhoff etwa hat diese Position in
unvergessener Weise großartig ausgeführt
seit antritt dieser Regierung dieser
Bundesregierung der Ampel ist diese
Position nicht besetzt das ist schlecht
und deswegen habe ich schriftlich
nachgefragt mit mehr als frustrierendem
Ergebnis denn auf meine Frage antwortete
mir Staatssekretär Michael ist vom
Auswärtigen Amt am 23 Dezember mit einem
kommentarlosen Verweis auf einer Antwort
auf eine Frage des Kollegen Hahn von den
Linken vom 29 juli ich habe mir
natürlich die Mühe gemacht mal
nachzusehen was das für eine wichtige
aussagekräftige Antwort gewesen sein
könnte am 5 August schrieb das
Auswärtige Amt dass eine Benennung
beabsichtigt sei man habe aber über den
Zeitpunkt und eventuelle Anpassungen der
Aufgabenbeschreibung noch nicht
entschieden das war am 5 August heute
haben wir den 25 Januar passiert ist
nichts und das ist peinlich
es ist auch ein Versäumnis gegenüber
Belarus der belaristischen und
russischen Oppositionen der gesamten
Region die Menschen schauen nämlich mit
unglaublicher Hoffnung auf Berlin und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir dass
wir agieren ich schlage daher vor dass
anstelle des bisherigen Chorus wie das
in der Beamten Sprache heißt ein
kostufen wird ein Koordinator für die
östlichen Beziehungen Hauptaufgabe
Kontakt zur demokratischen Opposition in
Belarus und Russland dazu Koordinierung
der zivilgesellschaftlichen Begleitung
des Weges der Ukraine von Moldau und
Georgien in die Europäische Union
und die Koordinierung des
zivilgesellschaftlichen Kontakts nach
Aserbaidschan und Armenien und
Zentralasien einen ko-ost und wenn sie
aus ihren Reihen offensichtlich im
letzten halben Jahr niemand geeignetes
gefunden haben fragen Sie uns wir haben
gute Leute aber vor allem ernennen Sie
bitte einen Koordinator für diese
wichtige Aufgabe noch einmal
Hauptaufgabe Koordinierung unserer
Unterstützung für die Opposition in
Belarus und Russland
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
gut dass wir heute über Belarus sprechen
ich freue mich sehr auf den weiteren
Verlauf der Debatte genau zu hören wer
sich wie zu diesem blutrünstigen Regime
äußert denn je mehr Aufmerksamkeit
Belarus erfährt desto besser und bitte
unterstützen Sie unseren guten Antrag
vielen Dank
soweit der Obmann im Ausschuss für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe der
Unionsfraktion Knut Abraham ich
bezweifelt dass die Ampelkoalition auf
dieses Angebot eingeht sich bei
Personalfragen bei der Union zu bedienen
aber vielleicht irre ich mich dort Nils
Schmied spricht nun für die SPD-Fraktion
der außenpolitische Sprecher und Herren
Eduard palchis ist 32 Jahre alt und seit
2014 ein engagierter meinungsfreudiger
Blogger der mehrfach inhaftiert wurde
und im Zuge der Proteste 2020 erneut
hinter Gittern landete er wird der
Organisation von Ausschreitungen der
Organisation und Vorbereitung von
Handlungen die die öffentliche Ordnung
versetzen bezichtigt und wurde im
Dezember 2021 zu 13 Jahren Haft in einem
Hochsicherheitsgefängnis verurteilt
seine Frau war gezwungen das Land zu
verlassen und meiner Verhaftung zu
entgehen sie lebt jetzt außerhalb von
Belarus und darf maximal einmal pro
Monat mit ihrem Mann telefonieren
dass nach der Verhaftung von Eduard
palchis geborene gemeinsame Kind hat den
Vater noch nicht kennengelernt
Eduard palchis sehr verehrte Damen und
Herren steht stellvertretend für etwa
1.500 politische Gefangene die Opfer der
brutalen unterdrückungswelle von
Lukaschenko in den letzten
mehr als zwei Jahren geworden sind und
der Bundestag hat
128 Patenschaften für solche politische
Gefangene unternommen ich die für Eduard
palchis und über 300 solcher
Patenschaften sind vom Europäischen
Parlament und von zahlreichen nationalen
Parlamenten in Europa übernommen worden
und genau das ist der Punkt und da
stimme ich dem Kollegen Abraham
ausdrücklich zu es ist gut dass wir es
gemeinsam schaffen parteiübergreifen die
Aufmerksamkeit auf yelarus gerichtet zu
halten es ist gut dass wir diese
Unterdrückung nicht hinnehmen dass wir
Eintreten für die Freiheitsrechte des
Volkes und jedes einzeln der
Staatsbürgers von Belarus und es ist gut
dass die
Opposition im Exil unterleitungen von
Seitan hat sich ein Oskar ja nicht nur
geeint auftritt sondern ebenfalls ihren
Beitrag dazu leistet die Aufmerksamkeit
hochzuhalten und das Schicksal von
pelarus dieses kleinen Staates im Herzen
Europas nicht in Vergessenheit geraten
zu lassen und wir alle haben diese
Aufgabe diese Aufmerksamkeit weiter
hochzuhalten das ist das was wir den
Menschen in Belarus Schulden
es ist völlig klar die Legitimität von
Lukaschenko ist zerstört er hat
keinerlei demokratische legitim
Legitimation mehr und auch aus der
Gesellschaft heraus wissen wir ganz
genau dass dieses Regime am Ende ist es
ist nur noch die Frage wann ein Wandel
vollzogen werden kann und wie immer bei
großen Befreiungsbewegungen in
unterdrückten Gesellschaften können wir
von außen schwer einschätzen wann der
Moment kommt es kann noch Jahre dauern
der in Unterdrückungsapparat ist brutal
und sehr gut eingespielt aber für uns
muss analytisch klar sein der Weg von
Belarus ist eine der nur nach vorne
gehen kann es wird kein Weg zurück zu
einer Herrschaft von Lukaschenko und
einer ein Partei indiktatur geben die
Freiheit Hoffnung und die
Freiheitsbewegung in bielers wird sich
durchsetzen und darauf müssen wir nach
unserer Möglichkeit arbeiten nach
Kräften hinarbeiten
dazu gehört dass wir daran festhalten
politische Gefangene müssen sofort
freigelassen werden und die Menschen im
Belarus müssen die Möglichkeit haben in
freien und demokratischen Wahlen über
ihre politische Führung zu entscheiden
diese Forderung haben wir seit August
2020 erhoben wir halten daran fest auch
in Belarus muss es möglich sein dass
jeder und jede über drin weiteren Weg
des Landes frei in freien Wahlen
entscheiden darf
und wir warnen ausdrücklich die Führung
in Minsk davor sich an dem russischen
Angriffskrieg aktiv zu beteiligen mit
eigenen Streitkräften schon jetzt
ist Yellows Rückzugsraum und aufmaßraum
und
Trainingsraum für die russischen
Streitkräfte
eine Beteiligung
ein weiteres schweres Verbrechen
und es würde vor allem auch Belarus und
die belarussische Gesellschaft zerreißen
deshalb kann man nur darauf hoffen dass
die Herrschenden in Minsk vor diesem
Schritt zurückschrecken wir jedenfalls
werden nicht müde darauf hinzuweisen
dass dieser Krieg in der Ukraine auch
für das weitere Schicksal von Belarus
entscheidend ist wenn Russland in der
Ukraine scheitert ist das auch ein
Hoffnungszeichen für die Zukunft von
Bärlauchs
wir werden von unserer Seite alles dafür
tun Verbrechen festzuhalten und zu
verfolgen wir werden humanitäre Visa
weiter
leisten wir werden die Exil Opposition
die Arbeit freier Medien aus Belarus im
Exil unterstützen ja nach ihrer
Bewerbungsrede lieber Kollege Abraham
will ich darauf hinweisen diese
koordinatorenfunktion wird auch in
Zukunft eine wichtige Rolle in unseren
Beziehungen zu Osteuropa spielen müssen
allerdings geben Sie uns die Chance zu
überlegen wie wir sie neu strukturieren
müssen denn eins geht wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr oder ich bin ziemlich sicher
es geht nicht mehr dass wir einen
Koordinator bestimmen der sowohl für
Russland wie für Ukraine zuständig ist
nach dieser Geschichte wird das
nicht nur möglich sein wir werden also
das neu strukturieren müssen aber ein
herausgehobener an ist auch unsere
Wunsch herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit die Ankündigung von Nils Schmid
der natürlich auch darauf verwiesen hat
die Rolle Belarus im Krieg Russland
gegen die Ukraine ist natürlich
entscheidend auch in der Frage der
Weiterentwicklung des Landes Eugen
Schmidt jetzt für die afd-fraktion
Liebe Landsleute
2020 kam es möglicherweise zur
Wahlfälschungen bei der Präsidenten weil
in Weißrussland dieser führte den Wochen
darauf zu Massenprotesten Golos eine
nichtregierung zur Organisation der
weißrussischen Opposition nah steht kam
gleichwohl zum Schluss das Lukaschenko
die Wahl mit fast 62% gewonnen wie
gelangt die Union dann zum Schluss das
Haus wie planetech Hannover
2020 sein müsste
ob die Mehrheit der weißrusssen hinter
der Führung oder oder Opposition stand
können wir nicht wissen wir kennen
diesen einseitigen Blick er dient der
Vorbereitung ihrer immer wieder
scheiternden Regimewechsel diese enden
erfahrungsgemäß in Chaos
Flüchtlingsströmen und einem mehr von
Blut
wer soll ihren Antrag Belarus in die
europäische Völkerfamilie zurückführen
ernst nehmen die Union hat doch ein
völlig gespaltenes Verhältnis zu
vertragsdrohe und Anstand
Angela Merkel erklärte vor wenigen
Monaten sie habe die Umsetzung der
münzka Vereinbarungen nie beabsichtigt
Deutschland hatte nicht vor die Chance
auf einen friedlichen Ausgleich in der
Ukraine zu nutzen
stattdessen wurde Russland sanktioniert
weil jasminsknoe unzureichend umsetze
das ist wohl eine Politik eine Täuschung
vertragstreuung Diplomatie sind
Fremdworte für sie ihre Politik ist die
von Sanktionen und Spannungen die Union
äußert sich in ihrem Antrag sogar
zugunsten von Personen die Sabotage
Handlungen durchführen im Sinne der
Definition Terroristen ja es gibt wohl
über 1000 Menschen die aus politischen
Gründen in Weißrussland in Kraft hier
sind diese stehen aber in direkten
Zusammenhang mit ihrer regime-change
Politik
viele Jahre gab es dort nur für
einzelpolitische Gegner
sie zeigen mit dem Finger auf
weißrussmustern und was ist mit Julian
Assange denn das Wochenblatt die Zeit
als politischen Gefangenen bezeichnet er
sitzt seit vier Jahren im Gefängnis ohne
Prozess und sie alle schweigen denn
Assange kämpft gegen einen ausrufenden
globalistischen masterparat das war sie
entweder selbst unterstützen oder
billigend in Kauf nehmen
Weißrusslands Bevölkerung leidet die
Steuern sind gestiegen viele westliche
Unternehmen haben das Land verlassen
gleichzeitig schreiben sie in ihrem
Antrag dass Sie zwischen der lukaschenke
Regierung und der Bevölkerung die
finanzieren wollen und in Deutschland
sieht das auch nicht besser aus so hat
das Einfuhrverbot für junge
mittelausweis Russland die junge
mittelpreise eine Zeit lang mehr als
verdoppelt dies hat erstens dazu
beigetragen dass hunderte vielleicht
tausende deutsche Bauern aufgeben
mussten zweitens treiben die Sanktionen
die Inflation in die Höhe noch nie in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik gab es
so hohe real,-
das ist nichts anderes als eine
Enteignung des deutschen Volkes
das ist die verheerende Bilanz ihrer
Politik
Deutschland
galt jahrzehntelang als Land der
Vertragstreue und Ausgleichs daran haben
die Kanzler Adenauer Brand Schmid Kohl
und Schröder hat gearbeitet
sie aber treten dieses Erbe mit Füßen
durch ihre Sanktionen Waffenlieferungen
und Regime wechseln sie brauchen eine
andere eine bessere Außenpolitik dazu
sind sie nicht imstande die FD steht für
deutsche Interessen und für Frieden
danke
vielen Dank
Schmidt war das für die
afd-fraktion für die Grünen Fraktion
spricht nun Robben Wagner er ist der
europapolitische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auf diese sowohl Putin als auch
Luca Schenker Propaganda Rede gehe ich
gar nicht erst eine bräuchte ich mehr
als eine komplette Redezeit für das war
so viel Protest ist ich will ihn lieber
stattdessen von Paulina erzählen Paulina
ist ein vierjähriges Mädchen und sie
lebt mit ihren Eltern in Baran Avicii
einer Stadt südwestlich von Minsk
der Vater von Paulina ist eherlosig ih
ist Journalist und eins der bekanntesten
Gesichter der belarussischen
Demokratiebewegung
ihrer wurde im Juli 2020 verhaftet weil
er sich für faire und freie
Präsidentschaftswahlen eingesetzt hat da
war Paulina gerade einmal zwei Jahre alt
Paulina hat ihren Vater seitdem ein
einziges Mal gesehen im Gefängnis hinter
einer dicken Glasscheibe
für eine Umarmung und erreichbar
wurde im Dezember 21 in einem
Schauprozess des Regimes zu 15 Jahren
Haft verurteilt das Regime will in
mundtot machen aber das Gegenteil ist
passiert es gab und gibt sehr viele
laute Stimmen die sich für ihas
Freilassung für ihres Ziel eines
demokratischen Belarus einsetzen und
eine der lautesten stimmen und die
mutigste davon war immer seine Frau
Daria die Mutter von Paulina
im letzten Oktober vor knapp drei
Monaten wurde Daria in den frühen
Morgenstunden in ihrer Wohnung verhaftet
sie und Paulina schliefen noch
Paulina musste mit ansehen wie ihre
Mutter von Männern in schwarz
mitgenommen wurde wir können nur erahnen
wie sehr und wie schmerzhaft diese
Eindrücke Paulinas Leben prägen werden
Daria wurde letzte Woche zu zwei Jahren
Haft verurteilt weil sie sich
unermüdlich für die Freiheit ihres
Mannes eingesetzt hat und Paulina lebt
nun bei ihren Großeltern
sie hat ihre Mutter seit der Verhaftung
nicht mehr gesehen
Lukaschenka hat der kleinen Paulina das
Wichtigste in ihrem Leben genommen die
tägliche Geborgenheit ihrer Eltern ihren
Halt und ihre kleine Welt das ist die
menschenverachtende Politik von Diktator
Lukaschenko
zurzeit sitzen laut der belarussischen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen wie Jasna
über 1.400 politische Gefangene
unschuldig im Gefängnis der Kollege hat
gerade schon darauf hingewiesen und über
100 von uns liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen haben parlamentarische
Patenschaften übernommen um auf diese
Gefangenen aufmerksam zu machen das ist
wichtig
und das ist seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffs Kriegs auf die Ukraine noch mal
mehr wichtig denn wir dürfen und werden
die belarussische Opposition nicht
vergessen es wird Lana tichonosca ja
natürlich ja Maria karlesnikowa alleski
und viele weitere mehr hatten im Sommer
2020 den Mut sich gegen die vermeintlich
letzte Diktaturen Europa aufzunehmen sie
wollten durch faire und freie Wahlen
durch friedlichen Protest die Diktatur
von Lukas Schenker beenden
wir wissen leider dass es anders kam
lukaschen prügelten die Opposition
brutal niedersperrten sie ein drängte
sie ins Exil zu viele bezahlten den
Protest mit ihrem Leben
lukaschenke hat im Sommer 2020 seine
historische Chance verpasst er hat sich
für Terror statt Demokratie für Angst
statt Freiheit für putinsdiktatur statt
demokratische Öffnung entschieden
am 24 Februar des letzten Jahres haben
russische Truppen von Belarus aus die
Ukraine angegriffen von belarussischem
Boden aus wurden seitdem wiederholt
Raketen auf ukrainisches Territorium
geschossen und erst vergangenen Monat
fand ein gemeinsames Militärmanöver
russischer und belarussischer
Luftstreitkräfte statt es besteht
überhaupt kein Zweifel Diktator Lukas
Schenker unterstützt Putin in seinem
brutalen Krieg gegen die Ukraine es zur
Marionette des Krems geworden
aber Hunderte belarussische
Oppositionelle haben sich der
ukrainischen Armee angeschlossen sie
haben ein eigenes Regiment aufgebaut sie
helfen die Ukraine zu verteidigen denn
sie sind überzeugt nur mit einer freien
Ukraine ist auch ein freies Belarus
möglich und deshalb dürfen wir nicht
müde werden die Ukraine und die
belarussische Demokratiebewegung zu
unterstützen wir dürfen nicht nachlassen
solidarisch an ihrer Seite zu stehen in
Wort und Tat dafür braucht die Ukraine
die notwendigen Mittel für den so
wichtigen Sieg in wirtschaftlicher in
humanitärer Hinsicht und eben auch in
militärischer Hinsicht und da bin ich
sehr dankbar für die ganz aktuellen
Entscheidungen für die starke
Unterstützung des Bündnisses aber lassen
Sie uns auch solange es nötig sein wird
die belarussische Demokratiebewegung
unterstützen es war und ist richtig dass
wir humanitäre Visa an politisch
Verfolgte bereitstellen dass wir
zwangsexmatrikulierte Studierende und
Wissenschaftlerinnen sowie die Arbeit
von unabhängigen Medien unterstützen
Lukaschenka und seine Schergen müssen
für ihre Verbrechen vor Gericht gestellt
werden die Sanktionen
die Sanktionen gegen das belarussische
Regime sollten wir immer wieder
überprüfen und Schlupflöcher
gegebenenfalls schließen und wann immer
wer uns mit harter Kritik gegen das
Regime wenden da müssen wir gleichzeitig
klar machen wer für uns wirklich für
Belarus steht es sind die mutigen
Menschen der demokratischen
Zivilgesellschaft es sind diejenigen die
im Land unter großen Gefahren oder die
erzwungenen Exil für die Freiheit ihres
Landes für Demokratie und Freiheit
streiten und diesen Belarus in weiß rot
weiß gilt unsere volle Unterstützung und
auch deshalb
und auch deshalb dürfen wir nicht
nachlassen uns weiter für die
Freilassung aller politischen Gefangenen
einzusetzen das sind wir Paulina
schuldig Kinder brauchen ihre Eltern
europa braucht ein demokratisches
Belarus europa braucht eine befreite
Ukraine und die Menschen brauchen
Freiheit vielen Dank
Robin Wagener war das für die Grünen die
Ukraine hat übrigens Vorwürfe
zurückgewiesen die es aus Belarus gab
dass die Ukraine Belarus angreifen
möchte der Präsidentin hat gesagt wir
hatten und haben nicht Vorbild daraus
anzugreifen Thomas Lutz und spricht
jetzt als nächstes
über das was in den letzten Monaten und
Jahren in der Republik Belarus passiert
ist und wie man es bewerten muss besteht
hier im Parlament wahrscheinlich eine
sehr große Einigkeit mal ausgenommen von
der Fraktion am rechten Rand vor diesem
Hintergrund sind wir den Antragstellern
sehr dankbar dass sie das Thema hier
noch einmal einbringen
denn es darf nicht sein dass im stadtten
des Krieges gegen die Ukraine ein
Nachbarland fast vergessen wird welche
sich zumindest indirekt an diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
beteiligt auch wenn Belarus hier eher
der Mitläufer und weniger der ergress so
ist die Mitverantwortung an diesem Krieg
bleibt eindeutig erhalten
der vorliegende Antrag beschreibt nach
meiner Auffassung sehr treffend die
aktuelle politische Situation in und
Bella aus unsere Aufgabe ist es die
zivilgesellschaftliche und die
demokratische Opposition in Belarus und
im Exil zu unterstützen und solidarisch
zu sein
wie kann das konkret aussehen ein
Beispiel
der Deutsche Bundestag hat die
sogenannten parlamentariergruppen sie
stehen im direkten Kontakt zu dem
Parlamenten in den Ländern aller
Kontinente und haben auch direkten
Kontakt zu gesellschaftspolitischen
Akteurin in diesen Ländern weltweit im
Falle von Belarus oder die vorhandene
Parlamentariergruppe zu Kriegsbeginn
aufgelöst
was auf den ersten Blick vollkommen
nachvollziehbar war hat aber auch
politische Nachteile
eine Parlamentariergruppe wie im Fall
von Belarus muss ja nicht unbedingt das
Land selbst besuchen um dort den
herrschenden den Hof zu machen eine
solche Parlamentariergruppe kann sehr
wohl direkt in Kontakt zu
Oppositionellen im Land und um Exil
aufnehmen dies hätte
eine ganz andere Wirkung als das beim
Respekt wenn es einzelne Abgeordnete
gemacht
deshalb in Richtung der Fraktionen
lassen Sie uns noch einmal sehr genau
überlegen ob es beim Thema Belarus nicht
hilfreich wäre wenn unsere
Parlamentariergruppe wieder eingesetzt
wird
auf die weitere Behandlung des Antrags
der Union sind wir sehr gespannt er ist
inhaltlich geeignet zu einem gemeinsamen
Antrag aller demokratischen Fraktionen
sich zu entwickeln allerdings müsste
sich da die CSU-Landesgruppe endlich mal
von ihren antiken Befindlichkeiten
überwinden und ist der Unionsfraktion
möglich machen gemeinsame Anträge mit
der Linksfraktion zu machen und
verabschieden ich glaube hier geht es um
den Inhalt und ich um irgendwelche alten
Etiketten vielen Dank und herzlich
willkommen
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
Lutze war dass das hier übrigens einige
Abgeordnete von Lukaschenko oder
Lukaschenko sprechen hat damit zu tun
dass es zwei Varianten des Namens gibt
einmal die russische und die
weißrussische
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in der ersten Novemberwoche des
vergangenen Jahres wurden unter
Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit Irina
Melker und ihr Sohn Anton Maker vor
einem Gericht in galleros verurteilt
Anton Maker wurde zu einer Haftstrafe
von zweieinhalb Jahren seine Mutter
Irina zu 17 Jahren Gefängnis sowie zu
einer Strafe von ungerechnet 8.800
US-Dollar verurteilt der Vorwurf gegen
Irina und ihren Sohn Anton
terroristische Aktivitäten es sind nur
zwei Namen von Menschen die sich an
Protesten gegen das repressiv repressiva
Regime Alexander lukaschenkoes beteiligt
haben ich habe für die beiden die
politische Patenschaft übernommen und
mache immer wieder auf ihr Schicksal
aufmerksam sie sollen in dieser Rede
stellvertreten für die tausende Menschen
stehen die sich im delarus in
politischer Haft befinden
darunter auch der Mann der Villa
russischen exilchpositionsführerin
Svetlana tichanowskaja sehr geilowski
die Bürgerrechtlerin Maria kolesnikowa
der Friedensnobelpreisträger des Jahres
2022 und Vorsitzende russischen
messtrichzentrum Jasna alleski und viele
viele mehr ihr Schicksal ungewiss
der zu Debatte stehende Antrag der Union
trägt den zuversichtlichen Titel Belarus
in die europäische Völkerfamilie
zurückführen den Freiheitswillen der
Menschen unterstützen dies ist ein mehr
als wünschenswerter Anspruch nach den
Massenprotesten im Zuge der
Präsidentschaftswahlen im Jahr 2020 und
der indirekten Teilnahme des Regimes in
Minsk als versalmstadt der Russischen
Föderation und völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ist
Belarus derzeit in Europa isoliert er
denn je
jegliche Form zivilgesellschaftlichen
Engagements oder politischer
Oppositionen werden von Behörden und
Justiz aggressiv niedergeschlagen es
gibt Berichte von systematischen
aktivierungswellen Zwangsarbeit
willkürlich Justiz und Folter im
Fadenkreuz der staatlichen Verfolgung
Menschenrechtsaktivisten Journalisten
Medien schaffende Künstler
Oppositionelle Kriegsgegner
lgbtqi-vertreter und jeder und jede die
oder der sich in den Augen des Regimes
unerwünscht gegen die staatliche
durchdringen stellt
wenige Wochen vor seiner Festnahme
warnte der Friedensnobelpreisträger
Alessia wielecki vor einem Zitat
Nordkorea an der EU-Außengrenze und
sprach von einer noch nie dagewesenen
Vernichtung der Zivilgesellschaft
er stellt sich ein Gefühl der Ohnmacht
ein im Angesicht der mehr als
prekäranlage für Menschenrechte und
Demokratie in Keller aus
was können wir tun um die Menschen in
kellerrus bei ihrem Kampf für mehr
Freiheit und politische Mitbestimmung zu
unterstützen
einige offensichtliche Maßnahmen liegen
dabei auf der Hand und wurden von der
deutschen Bundesregierung und der EU
bereits umgesetzt so hat die EU in
Abstimmung mit ihren Verbündeten im
vergangenen Jahr bereits harte
wirtschafts-zeit Lukaschenko nicht an
diese Maßnahmen sind richtig wenn gleich
sie zu mehr Isolation in Europa führen
wichtiger denn je ist es daher heute den
Kontakt zur Zivilgesellschaft und vor
allem zur exilo-position zu suchen
seit den Massenprotesten gegen
Lukaschenko haben etwa 400.000 Menschen
das Land verlassen viele von ihnen an
die angrenzende Nachbarländer Litauen
Polen die Ukraine aber auch nach
Deutschland die belarussische Diaspora
organisiert Hilfen für geflüchtete und
Unterstützung für Menschen aus der
Ukraine und baut Netzwerke der für den
Widerstand aus dem Exil auf
Satana hatowskaja ist dabei die
wichtigste Klammer zwischen
Oppositionellen Exilgruppen europaweit
sie verdient uneingeschränkt
Unterstützung dabei können auch
Kultureinrichtungen Institutionen
unterstützen denn sie haben oft die
nötigen Mittel und eine breite
öffentliche Plattform
die Geschichte lehrt uns liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass ich
zivilgesellschaftliche und politische
Transformation unter den widrigsten
aller Umstände durchsetzen kann
der Kampf
der Kampf um mehr Freiheit der Kampf um
mehr Freiheit und mehr Demokratie und
Menschenrechte ist nie vergebens und er
ist es auch nicht im Jella Rose wo
normale Menschen wie Rina und Anton
mecker ihre persönliche Freiheit
vielleicht sogar ihr Leben für mehr
Mitbestimmung und Teilhaber riskieren
Alexander Lukaschenko hat allen Grund
zur Nervosität denn seine stimmen wenn
die Stimmen jener die mehr Mitbestimmung
und Demokratie fordern werden nicht
verstummen und wer wir werden Sie mit
allen unseren Verfügung stehenden
Mitteln unterstützen wir unterstützen
Fries ich danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Nico Glogowski Merten nächster Arena ist
der
Fraktionslose Matthias Helfrich
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren es kann wohl festgestellt werden
dass niemand in diesem Hause die
Unterdrückung des belarussischen Volkes
durch Lukaschenko gut heißt
wünschenswert wäre es jedoch wenn die
cdu/csu Wahl Manipulation sie in Berlin
Exzesse der Obrigkeit gegenüber
friedlichen Demonstranten sie Corona und
die Unterdrückung alternativer Meinung
sie hat Dr Ganser in Dortmund mit der
gleichen Werft in Deutschland bekämpfen
würde wie sie es in Belarus avisiert ihr
Antrag geht von völlig falschen
Parametern aus denn er zieht die ewig
gleichen die ewig falschen Schlüssel aus
den Erfahrungen westlicher
interventions-
in Freiheitsdrang eines Volkes wird
niemand stoppen können keine Obrigkeit
keine Gewalt keine Unterdrückung dies
ist auch die Lehre aus dem deutschen
Revolution wenn wir aber beginnen die
Interessen der europäischen
Staatengemeinschaft mit denen des
us-nominiert nordamerikanischen
Verteidigungsbündnis ist gleichzusetzen
beginnen wir das aufzugeben was für
Belarus zu versprechen Glauben unsere
Souveränität
Europäer ihr Antrag wird als Mittel
dieser europäischen Einbindung Belarus
Sanktionen die nicht in erster Linie
Kollateralschäden erzeugen und eine
deutliche Reaktion der EU und ihrer
transatlantischen Partner doch wen
sollen Sanktionen verängstigen die denen
in den wirtschaftlichen Suizid Treiben
der sie ausspricht und wen soll eine
deutliche Reaktion verängstigen die von
einem Land ohne Waffen mit einer Führung
aus Kriegsdienst verweigern
ausgesprochen wird niemanden und deshalb
ist die Antrag auch keine Unterstützung
für die belarussische Freiheitsbewegung
sondern lediglich ein Flirt mit dem
großen Bruder an Übersee den Belarussen
kann man nur wünschen niemals Teil der
Europäischen Union zu werden wenn sie in
ihrem Antrag zu Recht anmerken hat
Belarus eine reiche Geschichte
Kultursprache und Identität der Preis
für eine Einbindung in die Europäische
Union wäre und das wissen wir als
Deutsche ganz genau die Aufgabe jener
eigenen Geschichte Kultur und Entität
ich wünsche daher den belarussischen
Volk kein Wechsel das hier die Mond
sondern echte Freiheit und Souveränität
als Nation vielen Dank
vielen Dank ein bisschen Applaus gibt es
da aus der afd-fraktion Matthias
Helferich wollte eigentlich in die
afd-fraktion aufgenommen werden
allerdings hat die Fraktion sich in der
letzten Sitzungswoche dagegen
entschieden sich mit diesem
Aufnahmeantrag zu befassen Tobias
Winkler ist der nächste Sprecher herr
Präsident sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
der Beitrag der AFD noch mal zu
unterbieten wäre gerade würden wir eines
besseren belehrt aber ich glaube damit
ist mein Vorredner auch abschließend
kommentiert
Belarus Belarus ist ein Schlüsselland
wenn wir auf die Sicherheitsarchitektur
Europas blicken jetzt und auch nach dem
Krieg gegen die Ukraine wir haben einen
Diktator Lukaschenko der sein Volk
unterdrückt aber dieses Volk dieses Volk
meine Damen und Herren das ist unsere
Hoffnung dieses Volk hat 2020 nach den
Wahlen bewiesen das ist die Repressionen
dieses Diktators das ist diesen
Repressionen die Stirn bietet das ist
den Mut aufbringt für ihre Rechte zu
kämpfen und das ist für die Freiheit in
einer europäischen Perspektive oder mit
einer europäischen Perspektive
bereit ist auf die Straßen zu gehen
bereit ist Haft Repressalien entgegen
sich auszusetzen und diesen Mut den
müssen wir unterstützen ich habe
es besteht die große Gefahr es besteht
die große Gefahr dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine dass das Spotlight von diesen
Menschen nimmt und deswegen ist es so
wichtig heute über diesen Antrag zu
sprechen diese Menschen nicht aus dem
Blick zu verlieren diese Menschen haben
wir haben Hoffnung auf dieses Volk diese
Menschen haben Hoffnung uns gegenüber
dass wir Sie unterstützen und wenn wir
auf Belarus blicken dann hat haben sie
Belarus hat Grenzen an die Ukraine an
Russland aber eben auch an Lettland an
Litauen und an Polen und wenn wir sehen
wie wir diese Staaten zuerst im Stich
gelassen haben als Lukaschenko mit
seiner menschenverachtenden
schleuseaktion Flüchtlinge an diese
Grenzen gebracht haben dann müssen wir
auch daraus die Lehren ziehen dass wir
diese Länder weiter unterstützen in
ihrem Kampf sie sind Exil für Menschen
aus der
Belarus die
Universität die ehu in Venus sie bekommt
die Unterstützung vom Europäischen
Parlament das sind ganz konkrete
Maßnahmen um dem Freiheitswillen der des
belarussischen Volkes diesen
Freiheitswillen zu unterstützen und
deswegen ist es auch für uns so wichtig
diese Unterstützung und mein Kollege
Knut abraham hat der einige Vorschläge
gemacht noch zu verstärken Belarus ist
Belarus ist wie es gesagt hat ein
Schlüsselland und wir dürfen dieses Land
nicht vergessen und deswegen war es so
wichtig diesen Antrag zu stellen diese
Debatte heute zu führen und die Menschen
die mutige Opposition auf Sky ja alle
die mit ihr kämpfen die in Polen in
Lettland und in Litauen im Exil leben
diese Menschen zu unterstützen und noch
an meinen Kollegen von der Linksfraktion
die CSU-Landesgruppe hat stellt es ihnen
völlig frei diesem Antrag zuzustimmen
nur dass dieses Missverständnis auch
ausgeräumt ist vielen Dank
soweit Tobias Winkler und damit kommen
wir zum letzten Redner in dieser Debatte
zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion das ist
Johannes Schraps für die SPD-Fraktion
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das Ziel Belarus in die
europäische Völkerfamilie zurückzuführen
ist in der Tat ein wichtiges und sehr
wünschenswertes Ziel und ich freue mich
dass auch die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aus der Unionsfraktion die den Antrag
erarbeitet haben das so deutlich im
Antrag ausdrücken und so sehen die
wichtigste Frage bleibt dennoch wie
können wir das tatsächlich erreichen
und mittelfristig können wir aus unserer
Sicht die wiedereinbindung und die
Demokratisierung von Belarus vor allem
dadurch voranbringen dass wir die
Ukraine in ihrem Kampf gegen das
putinistische Russland unterstützen und
indem wir dafür sorgen dass das
Nachbarland von Belarus sich
demokratisch weiterentwickeln kann und
dazu gehört auch die vorhandenen
Sanktionen nicht nur gegenüber den
belarussischen sondern auch gegenüber
den russischen Verantwortungsträgern
also gegenüber beiden autoritären
nachbarregimen aufrecht zu erhalten und
wo notwendig möglicherweise auch noch zu
verstärken denn ohne die Unterstützung
von Putin haben Lukaschenko und sein
Regime keine Chance ein freies bellavus
hängt eng mit einer freien und
demokratischen Ukraine und mit einem
freien und demokratischen Russland
zusammen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und darauf müssen wir hinarbeiten
in diesen Aspekt
den übersehen die Autorinnen und Autoren
des vorgelegten Antrags leider komplett
die Situationsanalyse in ihrem Antrag
ist ansonsten weitgehend richtig wenn
auch weiterhin sehr traurig und
frustrierend das bedeutet jedoch
selbstverständlich nicht dass man nicht
auch etwas für die belarussische
Zivilgesellschaft tun könnte obwohl
Putin und Luca schenkow an der Macht
sind wenn ein Land nicht demokratisch
regiert wird dann heißt das ja in der
Tat nicht dass es keine demokratischen
Kräfte in dieser Gesellschaft gibt und
diese sollten wir weiter unterstützen
diejenigen in Belarus und auch
diejenigen die das vom Ausland austun
richtig ist dass wir klar natürlich
janowska ja und ihrem exilbüro eine
besondere Rolle zukommen soll und muss
schließlich ist sie diejenige die bei
den Wahlen im August 2020 nach allem was
wir wissen eigentlich zur Präsidentin
von Belarus gewählt wurde gleichzeitig
dürfen wir uns aber auch nicht zu
einfach machen und uns nur auf die
Unterstützung ihres exilbüros
fokussieren denn die Belarus schon
Oppositionskräfte sind sehr divers
vorgestellt und wir sollten Sie deshalb
alle im Blick haben verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
mir ist an dieser Stelle
mir ist an dieser Stelle ganz wichtig
wie einige Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
noch mal darauf hinzuweisen dass wir den
vielen politischen Gefangenen in Belarus
helfen müssen nach aktuellen Zahlen sind
mindestens 1.420 Menschen aus
politischen Gründen in Haft Tendenz
Leiter wieder weiter steigend und wenn
Sie das Glück haben freigelassen zu
werden dann kommen viele von ihnen ins
Ausland auch zu uns nach Deutschland und
deswegen müssen wir uns um diese
Menschen kümmern verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen viele Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hier im Haus haben
Patenschaften für politische Gefangene
im Iran übernommen das ist extrem
wichtig und dennoch möchte ich deshalb
daran erinnern daran erinnern dass dies
auch für Belarus wichtig bleibt ich habe
seit 2020 die Patenschaft für Pavel
juckenwich aus der europäischen Gruppe
europäisches Belarus übernommen
er sitzt seit September 2020 in Haft und
deshalb rufe ich hier das belarussische
Regime heute auch noch mal dazu auf
lassen Sie Pavel und die anderen
ungerechtfertigt einsetzenden
Inhaftierten in Belarus frei
die Proteste nach dem gefälschten Wahlen
in Belarus sind mittlerweile zweieinhalb
Jahre her einige belarussische
proportionelle sind bereits damals
ausgereist und insbesondere diejenigen
die deshalb jetzt schon länger im
Ausland und zwar ins europäische Ausland
geflüchtet sind befinden sich
mittlerweile in einer rechts skurrilen
Situation denn ihre Reisepässe sind
mittlerweile vielfach ausgelaufen und
Sie können keine neuen Pässe beantragen
ohne erneut ins Visier der Bella
russischen Sicherheitsdienste zu geraten
Polen und Litauen haben sich bereits mit
der Problematik befasst und arbeiten
daran ein System zu entwickeln wie man
diese Situation pragmatisch lösen kann
indem man spezielle Reisedokumente
ausstellt die diesen belarussischen
geflüchteten auch weiterhin
Reisefreiheit ermöglicht wir sollten uns
dieser Initiative anschließen und ich
bin der Überzeugung dass wir diese
Schwierigkeit eigentlich auch europäisch
lösen müssen verehrte Kolleginnen und
gen also abschließend liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
sie haben mit diesem Antrag gezeigt dass
sie die Situation in Belarus mehr oder
weniger prägnant beschreiben können im
Großen und Ganzen das hat denke ich die
gesamte Debatte gezeigt sind wir uns
hier im Haus über die notwendige weitere
Unterstützung der demokratischen Kräfte
in Belarus auch weitgehend einig ich
habe ein paar wichtige Dinge
angesprochen die aus meiner Sicht in
diesem Antrag fehlen deshalb stellt er
aus meiner Sicht auch nicht so richtig
wirklichen inhaltlichen Mehrwert da weil
die Dinge die da beschrieben sind machen
wir zu großen Teilen schon dennoch
abgesehen von der Aufmerksamkeit die der
Kollege Abraham am Anfang angesprochen
hat ist da nicht so richtig viel mehr
drin ist es trotzdem gut dass wir den
Antrag in den Ausschuss überweisen die
Thematik weiter auf der Agenda haben und
dass wir uns dort gemeinsam für die
weitere Unterstützung eines
demokratischen Belarus einsetzen können
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
auch angenehmen Abend
so weit die Debatte hier zum Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zu Belarus es gab viel
Einigkeit aber auch das gehört ja einmal
zu einer Debatte dazu wir verlassen den
Bundestag für heute sind morgen
natürlich ab 8:45 Uhr dann wieder für
Sie da unter anderem starten wir mit
einem Interview zum
Jahreswirtschaftsbericht und der
aktuellen wirtschaftlichen Lage jetzt
geht es aber hier weiter mit den
Kollegen von der Tag und in persona im
Studio ist Maja Weber
endloser Regenwald das ist Guyana im
Norden Südamerikas seine Flüsse ein
Eldorado der Natur hier leben die Riesen
des Urwaldes
zwei Tierfilmer machen sich auf zu einer
abenteuerlichen Expedition um die wilde
Heimat der Urwaldbewohner zu erforschen
im Regenwald beide Folgen heute 20 Uhr
bei Phoenix
der Tag
willkommen liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer zu Phoenix der Tag es ist in
diesen Tagen viel von Geschichtsbüchern
die Rede